à à
anh alo chào các
anh alo Chào bạn
rõ hết cỡ chưa
tắt truyện I
chú ý Hôm hôm nay thì chắc là do bạn
thấy cái tựa đề rồi ông ạ nay mình sẽ
học về đặt Hà hôm trước và hôm trước
mình học với giỏ hàng rồi không ăn mình
sẽ học về kẻo khi mà ở nốt đặt hàng thì
nó bản chất là mình sẽ lưu lại những cái
gì thì sẽ xử lý như thế nào thì mình
không làm như mình đã nói là các bạn
chưa cần làm vụ thanh toán nhau ở phải
nhập thẻ thanh toán qua mạng thanh toán
qua thẻ ngân hàng hay liên kết cái gì đó
bởi vì mình
chưa Con Biết điều đấy Và và cái đấy là
bạn sẽ rồi mẹ thằng thứ ba nó sẽ cung
cấp thư viện cho mình để mình là nếu mà
đương nhiên là cũng phải đòi hỏi được là
mình phải đăng ký anh em nhiều cái để mà
cậu xác thực cho nó chứ Không chuyện này
được các bạn có một cái thẻ đấy cứ khách
hàng nhập và với khách hàng mất tiền với
Google được đúng ạ
Ê chúng mày Cái đèn nó rất là lằng nhằng
nên mình sẽ không dạy các bạn ít nhất là
ở cơ bản không ạ ạ
ở nhà bây giờ thì tranh thủ tâm sự trước
đã nhỉ em chụp ở đây tôi sẽ có hại Hôm
nay tôi sẽ có hai cái Linh để mấy ông có
thể xem một cái là Em sắp ta như vậy
Ngân sách tăng
à à
Em sắp anh thì à
hình ảnh tượng cho con gái ông xem
à à
ừ ừ
are you tube nó đáng sợ YouTube đánh bản
quyền âm thanh nữa chúng ta chuyển qua
xem phim này em có bị gì không
Ừ chắc không dám đâu
à à
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
anh ạ
hi
ceri share something happened Today so
wait and see the basic tạo lập những
protein đến bệnh viện để giao simpler
syntax
to use of prisoners and life Happy
không lại tham gia cuộc sống ở
[âm nhạc]
a
story Vinh à
à à
em
vừa rồi Các bạn xem có video các bạn
thấy đại ý của cái video ấy Thực ra nó
nó đã có trong tiêu đề rồi mà nói về
việc bỏ cuộc hay không
Ừ thật ra thì À
cái này tiện thể mình cho xem luôn cả
cái bài ở dưới nữa trước thì mình nói
con
gà Các bạn cũng chỉ cần đọc tựa đề này
được rồi Không cần đọc thì đọc tiêu đề
và tóm tắt thôi ông ạ
em đã từng có lúc em uống 71 viên thuốc
một ngày nhưng vẫn cố gắng làm việc để
đủ tiền lọ lo cho gia đình em cảm thấy
may mắn khi sinh ra với khối khối tài
sản vô giá là hai bàn tay trắng Nếu nó
mà em không bờ sợ khó khăn thử thách
trước mắt
Âm Nhạc
Ừ hai cái này mình muốn nói đó là
áo kiểu thực sự thì khi mà con người bị
đẩy xuống đến cuối cùng như thế Một là
chúng ta sẽ bỏ qua hay là người chúng ta
không có gì để mất cả mình chúng ta vẫn
tiếp tục chúng ta thiếu duy nhất chúng
ta đang có lúc đấy chắc chắn là trẻ hai
Phần Lan trạng hai bàn tay trắng anh đấy
người khác nhìn thấy nó là như thế thì
ra chúng ta còn cả hoài bão nữa cái hoài
bão khi mà
sau khi mà chúng ta bắt đầu
so với việc ở khi mà chúng ta vỡ bị đẩy
xuống sùng bái như thế Bị tất cả những
cái người thành công người ta chê bai
cái gì đó
anh không ạ
Mà cả thế giới quay lại quay lại quay
lưng với mình hiểu gì hết
khi mà chúng ta vẫn cố gắng có thể có
nhiều người sẽ bảo cái cảnh bảo các bạn
là bảo thủ chắc chắn bởi vì không nghe
ai cả thì có thì nó là bọn ngủ nhưng mà
khi mà các bạn chứng minh được và họ sai
và mình đúng ấy
Ừ thì cảm giác đấy thì mình tin à cũng
sẽ rất là sướng
A và Bởi bởi vì thôi à Không có một
người nào có thể biết được là các bạn
đang
đang cảm thấy gì đảm đã trải qua tất cả
những người nhìn gì đến được Đến Được
đấy thời điểm đấy
khi họ chỉ nhìn qua vẻ bề ngoài và họ
đặt bạn hơn họ và đấy Và nghĩ rằng nhà ạ
cái đấy khó quá Với họ họ trong trường
hợp của họ không làm được nhưng họ đâu
phải là bạn nên thành ra là
bạn bạn vẫn phải tự quyết định là ngoạn
mình Không khuyên được các bạn kiểu
Ừ cố gắng cố gắng đến nỗi là kiểu không
bao giờ bỏ cuộc
Ừ cái từ không bao giờ bỏ cuộc nó hơi
sai các bạn luôn mà nhìn nhận lại mình
đê xem cái này có đáng hay không và vân
vân vân Nếu mà các bạn mà bỏ cuộc một
cách dễ dàng thì các bạn sẽ không ngờ
Đạt đúng cái gì to tát cả cũng như là
các bạn vì sau sẽ ân hận tại sao mình
lại bỏ cuộc dễ dàng thế nó ngoạn các bạn
gần như ở toàn bộ những cái ân hận về
sau đều xuất phát được việc là các bạn
đã bỏ lỡ cái điều gì đã không làm điều
gì trong phải các bạn đã làm điều gì Các
bạn đã làm điều gì Các bạn ân hận không
bao giờ ân hận bằng kìa các bạn không
làm gì
Ừ cái đấy là cái mình muốn nói
à thực ra thì có nhiều bạn mà Ôi anh ơi
vẫn vờ vãi anh lại cái lý thuyết suông
ấy kia người nói đạo lý Xưa nay sống như
cái cái gì đó đúng ạ Nhưng thực tế thì
cái đây anh cũng là chính là trải nghiệm
của chính mình mày không nói là bây giờ
mình thành công sẽ sẵn rồi cho dù kể cả
lương nghìn đô trong nữa thì đường hẹn
mọi thứ bây giờ làm như mình nói được ra
nó cũng chẳng nghĩa gì cả nhưng mà khi
mà mình so sánh mình với bản thân so với
quá khứ khi mình không gì trong tay khi
mà mình không có nổi bạn bè theo kiểu
lại nói chuyện chẳng ai nghe chẳng hạn
đấy bây giờ ý sao có hiện tại đang có 40
Ông đang ngồi nghe tôi phải ngồi nghe
tôi hay vì hồi để trả cho anh nghe tôi
cả đấy Chẳng ai muốn nọ tiếp chuyện với
mình a real mình nha màu sắc mình nói
chuyện chán mình không Mình nghèo mình
mình hiểu đủ thứ vẫn còn Vân
thì biết là ít ra ở chắc chắn của tôi
rồi khác xưa khá nhiều nếu các bạn đặc
biệt là bạn thân của tôi trong nữa
Nó cứ mỗi 15 nó có anh lại nhìn tôi thì
nó lại thấy à Ôi sao mày thay đổi như
thế không phải thay đổi về bé ngoài nếu
mà ông nào mà theo dõi tôi ở trên kênh
Facebook của tôi rảnh tôi so với ngày
năm xưa gần như các bạn báo của anh sao
trong anh vẫn vẫn thế chẳng khác gì
trong vẫn vẫn trẻ con như thế này nhưng
mà em còn nói về việc làm
sự thay đổi theo kiểu là
sự nghiệp hay Vân Vân tạm trữ mối tình
nhưng cái này sẽ khác thì sẽ thấy cậu
mình thay đổi một cách tích cực một cách
tích cực mình không vừa đánh mất cái kệ
con người bản chất riêng của mình là một
hành kiểu dụ điển hình là một thằng ghét
à
a z về chuyện tiền bạc
là một hành chính trực tiêu tiểu nghĩ gì
nói đấy
không số lệnh không kiểu nói chung cảm
biến thiết bởi vì tính mạng tính mình
thích kẹo cây ngay không sợ chết đường
đấy
thì tất cả những cái đèn mình vẫn giữ mà
mình phát triển nó ở chung nhà mình có
cái chính kiến riêng của mình và mình
dần dần thể hiện được cái chính kiến của
mình đã đúng cái kiểu như thế
anh nói chung là đấy để những cái thứ
mình muốn chia sẻ đó là việc là các bạn
là không hẳn là nên bảo thủ nhưng mà
cũng nên có cái chứng kiến và bảo vệ
được nó cũng như là kiểu có một cái gì
đó định hướng rõ ràng để mà làm một cái
gì đó đúng không ạ Các Bạn Bè Mình mình
phải khuyên thế phải vì thực sự tầm tuổi
các bạn bây giờ các bạn đang ngồi xe hả
mẹ thì chắc chắn là các bạn có thể cấp 3
để học
Em có phải bạn đi làm rồi có vài bạn đi
làm rồi nhưng mà nói chung Những Người
Bạn đang xem mình tin và phải đến nửa
nửa phần là ý thế là đang vẫn mông lung
ở tương lai bởi vì có nhiều ông vẫn còn
đang ngồi học lập trình của tôi cơ bản
tất cả mấy ông thực sự ạ có thể ra ngành
khác muốn học này hoặc là thậm chí à Ông
học trên trường nhưng chẳng hiểu gì cả
nhưng không mới phải học ở đây tôi nói
thẳng là như thế - có mấy ông hiểu dạng
thích thể hiện vào học của tôi bóc mẽ
thôi chứ Thì ông cũng rảnh đấy đúng ạ
Ừ Thì
Ừ thì tất cả những ông tôi chỉ khuyên đó
là kiểu mấy ông phải đặt sẵn những cái
mục tiêu luôn đặt ra mục tiêu và
mục tiêu không cần vậy
Mục tiêu cực kỳ khó có một mục tiêu rất
dày và mục tiêu rất ngắn phải có những
cái mô tiêu từng cột mốc như thế từ
trước các bạn không để ngay lúc đầu các
bạn chưa từng leo núi qua bạn đặt mục
tiêu ở đỉnh Everest thì ông không bao
giờ ông nghĩ đến giờ không đeo nó đâu
ông ạ Ông đặt từ mục tiêu bé bé sau đó
thì ông cứ Kiều cố gắng đạt được cái gì
thì ông thỏa mãn nào đã và quan trọng
tôi từng bảo là tôi có cách đó là tôi
chọn có người đi cùng một là bạn bè hay
là người yêu chồng ạ thì mình sẽ có động
lực để mà cùng đạt đến mục tiêu lấy hơn
hỗ trợ Ông đi một mình mà không được đi
xa được
à à
cô bạn kia vào ngồi nghe mình tâm sự để
giải trí thôi cũng được
ạ bây giờ như thế thì có lẽ tôi dậy Đúng
rồi tôi vào rồi thôi nhé nghĩ đó tôi
đang định quá giờ mới đi tôi xin phép
tâm sự em tí nhé
em Dựng 10 phút mình
à Mình mình đang nghĩ là mình sẽ phát
triển ạ thực ra mình không ý định phát
triển là kênh nha kênh trên như Facebook
lúc nào đâu Em vừa nãy mình nghĩa là có
khi mình sẽ tạm cái fanpage tên là gì
cũng là gi ti NL ở trên Facebook Thực ra
là có khá nhiều ông ấn gửi kết bạn tôi
hỏi cái theo dõi tôi ở trên Facebook mà
mếu không ai để ý là tôi đăng chẳng có
tí thì liên quan đến cái dân công nghệ
lắm không còn đang uống kiểu anh Mạnh
Tuấn Anh Mẹ tuấn hưng ai đang điều rất
nhiều cái mẹo về công nghệ chia sẻ và
công nghệ đứng cả chuyện hại về công
nghệ Còn tôi thì ít như thế cái trang cá
nhân của tôi đúng nghĩa là trang cá nhân
của tôi tôi thường hay đăng những cái
thứ mà tôi để mong là sau này là ngày
này năm sau tôi xem lại là chính chứ tôi
không có đăng mấy cái công nghệ lắm Ê
mấy ông sẽ bảo là
chỉ sau một khoảng thời gian để không
theo dõi tôi chắc là
tại sao tao phải theo dõi cây xanh thì
kia trong số chai như này rồi toàn đăng
mấy cái tao không có tâm nghỉ Cứu Thế
thì tôi đang định tôi sẽ tạo một cái
fanpage cũng theo bị danh của tôi Trái
tim và tôi sẽ thương ai chia sẻ những
cái thứ mất cảm thấy hay ho lên đấy tiền
hình à là cốt đoạn code nào hay đấy chứ
xe những thực phẩm chứa tôi chia sẻ
những cái tâm sự thôi ạ chia sẻ mấy cái
và chim vân vân hoa cả
anh nói chung những thứ tôi thấy hay
thậm chí là cả Âm nhạc luôn tôi tôi
Thỉnh thoảng tôi thích chia sẻ nhạc cực
Tôi thích con người thích nghe nhạc Tôi
sẽ chia sẻ là xinh bảo toàn bộ những cái
thứ tôi thấy hay Tôi rất thích chia sẻ
chia sẻ gần đây thì mấy ông có thể theo
dõi cái đấy thì tôi nghĩ là ổn hơn cái
tôi đang định sẽ tạo một cái fanpage
kiểu như thế thật giết tôi là ví dụ tôi
thích nhạc thể đoạn nhạc điện tử nạn tôi
sẽ chia sẻ lên đấy thậm giữa ảnh gái
xinh mà tôi thì xinh là đổi chia sẻ lên
đây thậm chí là cả về zota là nặn Tôi
đang thích một cái gì Họ nói Chúng tớ sẽ
chia sẻ hết lên đấy để ở nhưng ông làm ở
hợp gu của tôi kéo ra cùng chung giờ
thích thì sẽ xem được một vài cái đúng
không ạ Có nghĩa là thế khá hợp lý mà
không ạ à
Ê mày không thấy ổn không ạ Và thấy cá
có nhiều người bạn lắm phát triển để mà
nhiều người biết đến mình hơn ngoài ra
phát triển có thể phát triển group Bởi
vì nó có tương tác hai chiều nhưng mà
tôi thực sự ở Tôi ghét chứ việc là tạo
thêm group rồi là tên là kiểu nhóm Hồi
trước tôi từng tạo cái nhóm là lớp học
anh Long thì có rồi cho sinh viên của
tôi nhưng mà chủ yếu tôi đăng lên đấy để
mà tương tác với sinh viên của tôi cho
cậu ra ngoài tập thôi nhưng mà tôi nghĩ
bây giờ tôi bây hết sang fanpage thì hợp
lý hơn được ra ở khi mà Hồi đấy tôi từng
tạo lỗi các bạn kia sẵn rồi chia sẻ tự
cái gì đấy cả gần như tôi tự đăng mà tôi
tự đăng này tôi nghĩa rồi đang ở fanpage
hơn cả đăng group nên là Ừ bây giờ tôi
nghĩa tôi sẽ chuyển qua fanpage thôi à à
À đúng rồi mà cái cuối cho mày không xem
những cái thứ mà tôi thường anh xem trên
YouTube Không hôm trước tôi lại Xem lại
kể anh ra từ Phạm Anh đấy ờ ờ
Ừ anh đẩy cũng bảo là kiểu có bóng video
Anh ấy bảo là kéo có câu hỏi anh lấy họ
rất hay cho Tí tôi sẽ đăng lên hỏi trên
YouTube công ty gọi tâm sự Đó là
các bạn hãy xem gì trước khi ngủ
đó như thế này
cùng ai hay vậy chưa yêu kẹo là nó sẽ họ
được đá Chi ạ Con mở đa chiều nhưng ai
cũng có thể trả lời được ngoại thì
Ừ tí chiều cao là cái goose em của tôi
tôi cho mấy ông Xe này mấy ông đôi khi
là Mày có hợp với ông thể xem qua được
đấy Cái đang gợi ý đây rồi nhưng tôi cho
ông xem lịch sử của tôi thường này xem
gì à
Ừ để nó qua về mà con người tôi và thôi
cả tội chia sẻ một vài kênh mà mọi người
cũng có thể có cùng chung sở thích của
tôi ra mà không ạ nhất là tôi xem chim
sẻ đi nắng này để chết đấy nó ngoại tôi
thường xem game moba thôi tiếp theo là
tôi xem lại mấy cái video mà mình đã
từng dậy xem ạ mình dậy đoạn đấy Có ổn
hay chưa cũng nhờ xem lại câu hỏi các
bạn để tổng hợp phải câu hỏi này thế
theo tôi còn theo dõi kênh nha vật vờ
studio vì kênh này về công nghệ Thực ra
tôi không quan tâm hẳn về công nghệ ấm
bởi vì công nghệ thay đổi liên tục thật
là mang tiếng là dân công nghệ nhưng mà
mình không phải thức đây có phải thứ mà
tôi quan tâm đến cậu Chíp hay ở cái gì
đó camera Tôi thấy thực sự bây giờ mấy
cái đấy nó nó sẽ khác biệt nhau từng tí
từng tí một mỗi năm nay thay đổi một tí
thay vì cái kiểu tai thỏ biến thành nốt
ruồi gì gió tôi không quan tâm được đấy
một con Tâm cách người ta
3 cách người ta cậu thuyết chỉnh giới
thiệu một cái sản phẩm mà mình vốn là
mình không ấn tâm là họ vẫn chưa chỉnh
hay như thế có mình có Xem Châu Tinh Trì
hay mà Đấy thì khi thực sự thì mình học
mình học cách nói chuyện đấy À đúng rồi
nó có hình cái nữa chết hẳn rồi đấy tiếp
theo mấy ông nên xem mấy ông Khi mà ngủ
nên nghe nhạc à đừng đeo tai nghe nhạc
nghe không tốt đâu khi các bạn nên kiểu
Mở bài ca nhạc thư giãn không nổi thôi
Hồi tôi thi đại học tôi còn mở nhạc
opera rồi mày nghe nói là nó dễ tăng IQ
gì đấy
thế heo là tôi có xem yuta đúng ạ thì có
cái anh Super Hiếu này gần đó xe và 23
creative vn nữa thì mì anh đợi bình luận
cả hai nước mình học được cách bình luận
người ta ngoại không biết về sau tôi có
định làm bình luận viên hay không nhưng
mà thích cách người cách nói chuyện rồi
đấy 22 a
a tiếp theo đơn nhân baking soda bình
thường thôi ông ạ Đây bạn này xin phép
được
và đấy đi cũng là vật vào này Minh xô
này tại đại khái như thế này sau đó đi
Nhạc này Thu Nga của tôi sẽ là ngạc của
tôi khá là cũ Tôi từng nói Tôi có hủy
rồi còn thích nghe những nhạc cũ tầm 90
cậu
90 cả Việt Nam ở nước ngoài kiểu tầm đấy
đương nhiên là cũng có nhà Điện tử tôi
có nghe nhạc điện tử nhạc hiện đại Tôi
Có nhưng mà ít hơn so với Nga cũ
Có ai có nghe nhạc điện tử này có hư
hướng Nghe nhạc này mới không ạ Còn bộ
môn Tôi thích nữa là bộ môn Quốc cơ Quốc
Ờ tôi thích 3 game nhưng mà chả ai đi xe
bus game mà trên YouTube cả thì thể loại
Walker của cơ thì
các bạn thấy thời gian nó cũng có tính
toán hack não tí và có một tí nhân vật
tính thôi con người phá thích kiểu chỗ
cái thứ gì đó mình không đoán được bởi
vì à Tôi nghĩ nhiều Tôi thường ai đoán
được ngoại tình huống
và Quốc cơ gì cả các bạn đoán không ở
hết rồi khác tình huống đây này nó hay
đi
em yêu heo từ nhân vật này chắc các bạn
biết rồi nhân vật này cách chửi của anh
đấy à Của ông đấy ông ạ bạn chú đại khái
như hết thì
chỉ của
Ừ anh đợi cứ gọi anh ấy Chú ấy thì rất
là hay chửi thông Thúy cười và cái cái
cái cái chân like me này các bạn nên xem
ở điểm mới thứ nhờ các bạn cải thiện
tiếng Anh các bạn nghe được tiếng Anh
thứ hai đó là các bạn sẽ ở
Cho tôi xem những cái video này rất cảm
động bởi vì đây là video chương trình
thực tế ở bên Mỹ bên anh đỡ bất giác hơn
bên Mỹ thì thì đều là những cái quán rất
tồi tệ
khi được Kiểu ông này đến ông ấy trở
thay đổi thay đổi kể quan điểm người ta
thay đổi cuộc sống về ra luôn tại tôi
thấy kiểu giống như người thầy luôn Đấy
thế là tôi cũng xem rất nhiều video cảm
động của ông ai cậu khóc luôn đấy Kiểu
ông ấy thay đổi được Kiểu số phận của
nhiều người kiểu thế làm cho tôi toàn
hiệu lực là tôi muốn cũng cũng muốn
tương tự như thế
về game game này Tôi thích ca game mày
buổi không phải vì cái móng nghe mà ngủ
gì ạ Tôi không thích thần thoại Hi Lạp
em có mấy trăm other cái bộ phim thay
đổi khá nhiều cái con người bản chất của
tôi lại khác như thế và Ma Trận nữa Một
Huyền Thoại
ở công ty âm nhạc còn gì Thế cho các bạn
xem đúng rồi đây kênh tôi xem game nữa
thì tôi sẽ xem kênh mê game à tại kênh
phân tích game những Nói chung là các
bạn thấy nãy giờ ở tôi đều xe mà gần
trưa Xem chủ yếu là nội dung là một con
nói được ra tôi không chơi mấy game này
đấy Kiểu thế số xe mà Bởi vì à
anh nghe cách họ nói chuyện để mà tôi
nói chuyện cải thiện dân nghe cách họ
Phân tích đúng gridview thì gần đây tội
xem việc rồi livewell là gần như
anh đấy là cá nói chuyện rất hài hước
nhà mang tính kiểu châm biếm cập nhà
theo kiểu là giải trí Còn tôi xem mà tôi
vẫn đang muốn xem thiên hướng về cái
phân tích hơn nếu không hiểu ý thôi ông
ạ Đã là đúng hiểu đủ lý do giải trí là
có tí phân tích trong đấy có vui thì có
nhưng phải có tí động não trong đấy cái
rồi mình thích chứ tôi không ạ
a cho tôi không thích kiểu dạng mà chỉ
đơn giản giải trí
Cho tôi chơi game Tôi cũng phải cần máy
game kiểu na ná giống như cho ta này
chẳng nhắn nó con gì trai hot là đế chế
các kiểu thứ ở đây còn mọc phiện đã nghe
nhạc Thấy sao rồi xem xem thì tôi xem
thỉnh thoảng đón xem những cái điều nâng
cao trình độ bản thân ơi này nóng đầy
xót cho tôi mà cả hai cách
để anh từ phạm tôi vừa nói đấy
a monster morsi ôtô tuna nói trước đại
thái hồi trước tôi tôi có theo dõi anh
đấy và rồi tôi mới xe mình nhưng có cái
phốt cho anh đấy vì vậy à
Ừ Thật ra tôi đã từng nói Tôi không quan
tâm 10 phút thì cả nó không quan tâm mà
người đấy từng làm thận Thế đã làm đang
làm abc.xyz cái gì tôi không quan tâm
Không quan tâm đến việc cả anh ấy chia
sẻ cái gì có về ô tô xe
em lấy lại khá như thế Ok gửi sang
à à
Ừ ông kia spa nữ giờ Check Facebook bóc
hết hai tuần mà đây tôi không biết chị
mày không chưa Tôi có cài cái tiện ích
là ở
a web developer ngay để một phát check
luôn toàn bộ cái checkbox Nếu mà ý ông
kia hỏi là như thế
Ừ để tôi thử ví dụ cho em nhé
cho tôi Tôi vừa nãy tôi vừa dùng Xong để
mà tôi lấy cho Ken mà a rapper này
Có ai có cái tạo một tô canh mới này
Có
ai có cái toàn bộ trách box này đúng
không ạ thì mùi các bạn ship bằng ra
Swift để mà checkbox tích vào hai các
bạn cài tiện ích nhà thôi à Không bấm
nhầm đấy mình em ạ Các bạn tài tiện ích
này xong rồi ấn vào form này check cho
chết bóp xong mày đấy nhớ mẹ Ý bạn hỏi
như thế
anh
đứng đây làm nữa đó Đương nhiên thực ra
là không có một ai thực sự hoàn hảo cả
Nói chung là cũng khó vấn đề đạo đức hay
có sai lệch quá thì đúng ở không nên gen
Còn nếu mà những cái mà họ giống như ở
điển hình nhá Điền hình nhá Tôi đang dạy
mấy ông về lập trình nó ngoạn cái thì
khi mà tôi đang dậy ông bản thân tôi dậy
vẫn ổn chứ ra nếu không cần quan tâm
những cái đời sống cá nhân của tôi
chương kiểu đó tôi có
ABC sẽ gửi gió lời ca Không phải món Tâm
Ừ đúng ạ reset khi mỏng mấy ông rạch
giỏi về quan điểm đấy Giả sử là mấy ông
còn ăn kỳ dị người ạ người tình thứ ba
hay là người da đen Vân gì đó mà chính
cánh người ấy lại dậy ông nghịch tự
nhiên về sau mới biết được điều anh ạ
anh không ạ kéo quần tôi tưởng từ trước
nay ông ông con ngay ở em ạ Nhớ về hóa
ông con gái à Ông tội vì thế tôi không
nghe nữa tôi không em gái dậy trả lại
thế không Cái cái đấy cái việc riêng của
họ tôi không quan tâm đáng Nếu mày ra
cho những cái vấn đề ra đương nhiên có
những cái thứ mà nó hơi bị tiêu cực quá
nên hình giống như à à
cho ví dụ tôi con người yêu nước ạ Nếu
mà có có
diễn viên đóng bộ phim kiểu mà ông Hiếu
cuốc đây đóng những bộ phim
tài liệu về chính nước nhà kiểu thủybán
lịch sử của nước nhà vì rất là nó tôi
cũng lên rồi đấy nó phải như thế
anh hoặc là có nghĩa vụ Donut cho mấy
cái thần tượng Trung Quốc thì được tôi
thấy cái đấy cái gì chị không phải chỉ
thấy nó vẫn thôi nhưng mà tiền của họ mà
tôi sẽ không phải bán được đây là chỉ
phê phán vụ không ngờ xem phim thì bạn
lịch sử nữa nha thì thôi I
tự hào Tôi không biết thì ta tôi không
xem rất nhiều cá đâu thì cả không nhiều
thời gian để xem nhé Mấy ông có thể đề
xuất tí nữa sẽ đọc hết nha Giờ tôi không
nghệ vừa cho tôi sẽ trả lời câu hỏi đây
đã sau đó thì tôi dạy học còn tất cả
những cái bình luận của mấy ông thì ra
để bữa sau nha À đấy thôi Đang định ghi
nhiều bạn không biết được tôi sẽ phải
ghi lại là à
chị sẽ ghim lại để mấy bạn biết à
ở mọi câu hỏi mà mình chưa kịp xem 2 trả
lời thì mình sẽ tổng hợp lại và trả
rồi ở của sao ạ
chị
Linh có họ họ
cho
tổng hợp
đó à
anh xóa mấy cái sau đó hỏi chấm đi này
không cần này mấy ông chỉ cần quan tâm
cái này thôi nó như thế này à
anh làm sao mình chết hết sản phẩm khi
mà mình cốt à À Ý bạn là hình như là
đang nói về cái giỏ hàng đặt hàng đúng
không
Em làm theo kẹo Lộc khi đặt hàng các bạn
kiểm tra xem ạ sản phẩm để hết về chưa
Hay như nào nhỉ à
thì các bạn hỏi câu hỏi ở nó quay cái
vượt qua thứ tự này
em coi bỏ cái Linh đi nhưng chắc chỉ cần
nghe này
à à
ở bảng cái bảo đúng rồi là cái gì Đúng
rồi nghỉ à Ê mày nhiều người đã hỏi bạn
mà
Ok nó cho vợ
cho tôi tôi sẽ đi ý phần 1 câu hỏi sau
đi không bị phân tâm áp không dậy được
gì đâu
khi có thư mục
mà quên quên hỏi nó cái này nữa hay sao
đấy nốt này nữa còn tiền thì nhất là có
bạn hôm trước hỏi đó là các bạn đang làm
việc theo nhóm nó không ạ thì việc dùng
chung đang sân bay rồi Như thế nào là sự
các bạn muốn tạo hẳn đã tới đây để mà
các bạn dùng chung theo kiểu là các bạn
đang sản phẩm vào trong cái database đấy
thì người chưa nhận được bản chất cái
đấy đứng yên mà ờ ờ
khi bạn bắn chất Cái đấy là ấm chứ tao
bây giờ nó phải công khai tất làm chuyện
đó đẩy ra ngoài Nhưng đấy thường là để
làm được điều này thì các bạn sẽ phải
thuê hút sinh hoạt thêm cái thằng thứ ba
mà nó miễn phí không mất tiền tùy tiền
mà cho cả hai cùng kết nối vào nhưng mà
ở quy mô như thế hiện tại hiện đại như
bây giờ thì thực ra là các bạn chưa cần
phải đến mức độ đấy hoặc là Thậm chí các
bạn thuê cũng được mà miễn phí cũng được
thuê mất tiền nó có tí động lực Hồi đấy
tôi cũng thuê đấy có tính động lực kìa
mỗi ngày cảm thấy mất 3.000 tiền gửi xe
thấy thốn lắm trong 1 tháng 11 năm có
thuê một triệu mà Đấy Tôi có động lực để
ngày nào phải ngồi cốt có một cách nhờ
nữa Mấy ông không muốn kiểu như thế thì
mấy ông ạ
Có thể tách riêng bậc có thể hai bạn cốt
riêng debay ngoại chung cấu trúc là được
Nhưng mà tao tao bây dữ liệu nó có thể
không được nhau đi
Ừ đúng rồi có thể miễn phí nó chết cho
nó sẽ giới hạn một vài cái gì đó rồi
Không ạ Lúc để ngon được
Anh ở tiếp theo nhá Thực ra là hôm trước
tôi tôi chấm cho mấy ông từ gan nó có
một cái vấn đề nho nhỏ như thế này nó
nhau ở thôi đó là từ ra các bạn ạ nhiều
nhóm này nhóm yếu rồi không nói nhầm yếu
thì nên nó giống hệt cái mà tôi đã hướng
dẫn là quá đâu rồi nhờ vào những nhóm
khá Tôi thấy thì ra mấy bạn đang hơi bị
nạo thêm nhiều ra bay quá thì ra là như
tôi nói là cơ bản thì các bạn không cần
phải tạo quá nhiều như thế nhưng gần
nhiều tôi không thấy có nhóm nào thực sự
là làm ra tao bây theo đúng cái đề tài
mà các bạn thì đã chọn mà các bạn làm
theo kiểu làm thêm nhiều nó là cây ý của
tôi đang muốn nói nó nhìn lại tôi thử cứ
phải cho ví dụ mày ông dễ hình dung hơn
không ạ thì là sửa các bạn làm à trang
web bán về xe máy tính ở Lạnh thì cái
bảng sản phẩm các bạn đúng không ạ mã
sản phẩm các bạn thực ra là các bạn nếu
Để ý kỹ ở trên bất kì cái trang máy tính
nhà sự như là Trang Hà Nội công tơ
tôi không quảng cáo xanh này đâu Thực ra
tôi biết mũi trang này chẳng khám phá
thôi em
Các bạn thấy một loạt ở đây đó chính là
cái gì ạ Cái này thể loại Ok thể loại
các bạn thấy rồi nhưng mà con chia nhỏ
nhưng cái này nữa OK thì có thể thể đoạn
nhiêu cấp Okay tiếp theo nữa các bạn sẽ
thấy ở dưới này nó là gì ạ Nó có những
cái cái
Ừ cái có thể Peter có thể lựa chọn này
nó Peter Peter Peter như này tất cả
những cái này nó là cái gì ạ Cái này
không phải thể loại nữa Cái này cấu hình
nóng ạ cấu hình cái kiểu cái thế danh
mục à danh mục từ ra cũng được Nhưng
thật là cái này bản chất nó cấu hình hơn
và đây là đối với laptop cái là tôi thử
cho ông xem cái khác thì sao laptop nó
về cả
em nhảy sang
phím chuột này đi kiểu Nga
Nghe tin bão ngày thấy cái này nó gì nó
là hãng này giá này cũng lại cấu hình
thì chỉ đó nữa này tất cả cái này vẫn là
cấu hình ngoại cấu hình của bàn phím nó
khác với cấu hình của máy tính không ạ
Có không ạ thì thì cái bản chất là các
bạn à thiếu mấy cái những cái này nó lắm
chị ạ Nếu mà đã ta bây các bạn mà thiết
kế Hồi đấy là tôi bị từng bị trừ 1 điểm
vì cái vì cái vụ đấy Đó là
Ừ thứ Bảy có bạn hãy thiết kế cho cậu là
anh có thể dùng được cho mọi để tải
người ta Đấy là ta bây không chi tiết
Ừ tôi phải nói thế Tại sao ạ Giờ sự đây
có mã này có tên này có giá này có ảnh
này có mô tả này ông nhìn nó là bình này
ông cũng biết được đây đời tôi Bây này
bán thì cái gì không ạ khóc Không nhìn
này ông chẳng biết là bán được cái gì về
cơ bản thì cái này thể bán được mọi thứ
cái này ra tôi mẫu thì anh yên không nói
các bạn Thể Ôm nguyên như này không sao
Nhưng mà thực sự là cái đã tới Bây này
có thể bán được mọi thư đâu phải vậy mỗi
người tình đâu ạ đúng không ạ Đâu phải
10 mỗi linh kiện từ bản bánh mà ghé lại
được cái bán điện thoại cái này được cái
bán quần áo còn cái lại được Bởi vì tao
đây này đã ra đây một mức tương đối Đông
ạ Nó không chi tiết về một cái gì vậy để
ý tôi như thế
Đã thế lại chẳng chưa có nhóm nào làm vụ
này tôi cũng thử nói qua để những nhóm
khá nhé những ông khá Nếu mà muốn thay
đổi muốn sửa thì à Thì theo hướng của
tôi nó sẽ như thế này là sự các bạn vừa
rồi thấy cấu hình
các bạn không nên có một cột là cột cấu
hình luôn như nay ở trong này nếu mà các
bạn làm như thế này thì rõ ràng cái cấu
hình của một máy 1 máy có nhiều cấu hình
khác nhau mà không ạ Cứ kệ nó còn có thể
filter Tìm kiếm nữa thì không nên có cột
này như thế này ở đây mà nếu thế phải
tách riêng ra anh Chương ra nó sẽ là cậu
áo kiểu dạng nó là như thế nào Đó là
kiểu à
Ừ vợ ạ
Ê mấy ông thấy bản chất một máy tính có
nhiều cấu hình đúng ạ và một cấu hình
lại có thể thuộc nhiều máy tính đúng ạ
thì rõ ràng nó là mối quan hệ mờ mờ
Không ạ gọi là 1n bằng 1 n đấy không ạ
thì tức à cấu hình này
mã này tên này sau đó thì ở đây sẽ là
cấu hình sản phẩm trở lại và sản phẩm
cấu hình với
sản phẩm chi tiết vì các bạn đặt thì đây
sẽ la mã sản phẩm
mã tên
nhập mã cấu hình và đây giá trị họ gì đó
từ trường đã đặt tên là giá trị đầy giả
sử á là sự một ví dụ đi cho các bạn dễ
Hình dung là sự đây là máy máy một này
mẹ điều này không ạ và Vần đây xong rồi
một ở đây tên là ra mẹ nào đó ngoại thì
ở đây sẽ có mái một này mà cấu hình một
này cho món này hiểu ra mà Bốn ạ nhắn tự
ái hàng hay này nó sẽ là màn hình này
đúng không ạ đây sẽ là một này hay này
sẽ oled là chẳng hạn hoặc ips kiểu cơ
Thế thì mày ông nhìn thấy có thể và
đương nhiên để cũng sẽ nối lại cái này
cái này cái này để khi màn hình điện sản
phẩm da sẽ thì đầy đủ cấu hình của một
sản phẩm cũng như là vì sau mấy ông muốn
chỉ tìm kiếm tất cả những sản phẩm Ram
4GB em ạ khi bạn sẽ nối hai bà này với
nhau rồi các bạn tìm kiếm đồng mạ ạ ở
đây làm Đang tập bay thiết kế để cho về
cái gì thì cho về mộ Nhìn cái là có thể
hình dung được mình đang bán cái gì
không ạ Cái này có thể ôm xăng bán bánh
không ạ Không ôm bạn quần áo rồi ạ Không
thì các bạn Nhi nói đó Bây này các bạn
mới biết được nó là một đợt tao bây chi
tiết về một cái gì đó ông ạ
Ý tôi nói cái này thật ra nhiều bạn bây
giờ đang nghĩ buổi như thế anh em phải
sửa tao bay Gấp luôn không không còn nếu
mà nhóm các bạn mà làm mức tầm trung
bình hoặc yếu thì ra các bạn không cần
quan tâm này như mình đang gợi ý và các
bạn ngay bởi vì sợ thì tất cả các nhóm
từ nhóm khá mà mình thấy các bạn lại tạo
quá nhiều bạn lại không không đúng cái
đề tài đó sao các bạn tạo thêm bảng về
chat này với bình luận đấy xong rồi ở
Ừ mạng gì nhỉ Bằng nhận thông báo này
vẫn nó với những cái thứ mà thực sự thì
nó hơi bị Hơi bị đi xa phải toán một tí
cái cái cái
gần nhất với các bài toán đó chính là
cái gì đó là thịt là xem rõ được thông
tin của một sản phẩm thì các bạn đã
không có thế nên là mình thấy đó ạ Đây
mình mình sẽ nói cái này để các bạn à
anh hình dung được là các bạn phải phải
làm được một bài toán ở những mức gọi là
như thầy mình từng nói nó không lan man
mà phải khoan tròn trịa đã cho nó chị ạ
máy bay dõi đừng có la nan quá đừng có
thêm rất nhiều tính năng mà mỗi tính
năng chỉ được một tí tớ không cần mấy
ông vậy cô chú trọng vào một cái tính
năng mà nó rất là hoàn thiện hoàn chỉnh
thì ổn hơn để ý ông muốn nói về ngoại
rồi hôm trước của ông Tạm dẫn hai mươi
mấy Hai mươi hai mươi mấy với bạn thôi
em lấy sợ vãi đồ ăn 12 mấy cái bạn không
biết đâu bán hai ông ấy cho tôi bao
nhiêu chỗ à
ừ ừ
Ăn tim heo
Tại sao lưu thông tin liên hệ ở các bạn
order và bảng cúp summer
Ừ
thì à
ai dọn ra là không Trước Các bạn có thấy
là bảng hóa đơn của mình ông ạ hóa đơn
thì mình còn lưu lại thông tin người
nhận đúng là sửa là mình sẽ có một mã
này cột à mã khách hàng à
à à Ừ nhưng mà mình tự nhiên là mình có
thêm tên khác à và tên người nhận
số điện thoại mày ạ
Địa chỉ người nhận em ạ
kiểu nha các bạn sẽ thấy Ok Nhưng mình
không trước mình có bà à cái thằng đặt
chưa chắc là bạn nhận được ạ nhưng mà tự
nhiên trong mảng khách Hà
mình lại vẫn có mã có tên và số điện
thoại và có địa chỉ
Tại sao các bạn đã thắc mắc à Thế xong
thì hiểu tại sao lại như thế này ạ Rõ
ràng mà anh bắt người dùng nhập lại toàn
bộ Cái này thì mình lưu lại những cái
này cho mà khách hàng làm gì không ạ
Không mà chính hôm nay mình sẽ dạy các
bạn cái vụ này đó là khi mà đăng ký
khách hàng điền thông tin này một lần và
lưu lại không ạ Và khi mà đặt đặt hàng
ấy thì mấy cái này nó sẽ tự động tự động
điền vào tất cả những cái cái cột này
trước và người dùng chỉ phép sửa lại ghi
âm thể hiện người dùng không cần phải
điền lại vụ đấy Ừ thì cứ mỗi lần đặt
hàng rồi chồng lại phải điền lại tên số
điện thoại cho ra họ không Hay còn nếu
mà có bạn nào mà thích làm trải nghiệm
người dùng tốt hơn đấy là
thậm chí ở người dùng sửa cái tên người
nhận số điện thoại người nhận địa chỉ
người nhận rồi ra xử lại tôi thường ai
đặt đồ cho bạn gái chẳng thế thì tôi sẽ
ra một là tôi điểm tên tôi hay tôi điền
tên bạn gái chỉ thế thôi Mày không biết
cái bọn shopee đường ai có tạo tạo thêm
cả nhiều địa chỉ người nhận không ạ nhé
lắm chị ạ
Gọi tạm nhiều danh bạ chứ tạm ngưng danh
bạ làm chưa Một là tôi nhận hay là bạn
gái hư nhận chị hai người thôi thì có
mục lựa chọn nó đây chẳng hạn nữa ám chỉ
một là các bạn chọn lại những cái thông
tin cũ đã có sẵn của khách hàng này hay
ở các bạn Nhập mới thường các bạn chị có
một hạn hay người nhận thôi các bạn đỡ
Ừ cái việc trải nghiệm khách hàng sẽ tốt
hơn khi mặc các bạn khiến cho người ta
đỡ phải mất công gõ đi Gõ lại những cái
thứ người ra gõ rồi ông ạ lấy lại đơn cũ
hay hàng để mạnh đề xuất ra đây ông một
phương án khai ông ạ
à Tôi đang nói ví dụ thì thôi mày Ông
đừng có nghĩ quá nhiều mấy ông cứ ôm
nhiều quá rồi cũng không làm cái gì đâu
Thì em ví dụ thế
Ừ đúng
À mà đấy Cái mà tôi vừa tôi thưởng này
nói mấy ông đó lại tôi lấy ý từ những
cái ứng dụng mà người ông có thể đã dùng
rồi shopee cái hay mua bán bán hàng gì
đó mấy ông kiểu J mấy ông chẳng thường
dùng rồi đúng không ạ Mấy ông phải phải
thấy nó có cái gì hay mấy ông ôm về đóng
ạ Hãy tạo cho mình cái thói quen kéo cái
suy nghĩ ấy hiểu mấy ông ấy Đúng là dân
công nghệ thông tin không phải một khách
hàng bình thường nữa mà khi mày ông nhìn
vào cái thằng kia nó áp dụng với gì mấy
ông nghĩ tại sao làm được như thế nó làm
cái đấy bằng cái gì Và mấy ốp bây được
thì đấy mẹ Tư duy của một developer mà
nhà phát triển chứ không phải là kiểu
một người bình thường nữa mà em chưa
Tiếp theo
có mặn nói về cái bạn dưới tính tức là
cài á
thế giới tính hay làm
ở đây là sự này có bạn có bạn nhân viên
em ạ Hôm trước mình nói là sợ mã tên
giới tính ở đây sau đó thì mạ và cấp độ
em ạ Thì hồi trước mà mình nó là vụ là
mình có thể quy ước luôn không là nữ còn
một là nam này ạ Xin lỗi các bạn nữa thì
thì
Ừ mình quy ước như thế này bởi vì bạn sẽ
là thật lạ thường là giới tính theo kiểu
tóc theo sinh học đấy thì ra nói chuyện
ở hai thôi thì các bạn phải quyết thằng
ở trong cốt con nếu mà các bạn tạo theo
kiểu nó là mã giới tính ở Nga
Sau đó các bạn tách hẳn vậy bạc riêng
bạn giới tính có mã có tên như thế này
mở màn thứ ba cái này vốn dĩ nó chẳng Vợ
thay đổi vào nó cũng chỉ có 2 giá trị
Thôi thì mình thấy rồi ra hơi thừa tính
nhất là thừa thừa ạ việc cứ mỗi lần lấy
ra được giới tính là các bạn phải nối
tận hai ba thằng em nó bị kiểu bình Nặng
cũng như là nó con bị Hơi sai đó ra sao
vì thường mình phải thẳng Thế ba là để
mà mình thay đổi có thể thêm sữa xóa nó
nhiều thì mình phải tách hẳn ra cái ba
con việc ở dưới tính gần như cháu vừa
thay đổi được cậu không mới mổ thì các
bạn việc thêm không mở thêm dự tính mới
cũng không ở xóm dưới tính cũ đi Anh ra
à Cái này nó thừa tương tự thế với cái
cấp độ cũng có bạn bảo là em muốn tách
hẳn ra em không muốn nó không lấy một
giống như anh Bảo nữa em muốn có hành
bạn bạn cấp độ không ạ sau đó thì cũng
có mã cấp độ thì giống như mình vừa nói
về cũng tương tự với thằng giới tính đó
là Anh trừ khi về sau các bạn muốn thêm
nhiều cấp độ và sự cấp độ 1 thìa nhân
viên cấp độ 2 thư ký cấp độ 3 là giám
đốc cấp 4 là kia bố ra mốc này ạ kiểu
như thế thì mới tạo thêm phần mùa bảng
riêng để phân biệt các cấp độ còn nếu mà
các bạn chỉ có hai cái lỗ thôi thì thì
cho việc tạo trên bảng có thành thừa Bởi
mình không chỉnh sửa thêm sửa xóa gì nó
không ạ
a tiếp theo
anh có thể dùng cột email làm khóa chính
không Nếu các bạn có thể ý thì ạ
đôi khi mạn nhân viên hoặc cả bạn à
khách Hà
Ừ thì mình sẽ có cuộc Email là đệ mình
hơi để nó là muốn nick theo kiểu nó là
duy nhất ở ngoại tí mèo không bị chung
Và thậm chí khi mà các bạn nối vạn thì
ra nó có đề xuất là những cái cột Yoona
có thể làm quá ngoại trừ ra là các bạn
không nên dùng nó làm khóa ngoại
Ừ thế này cũng không nên dùng nó nó khóa
trình luôn tại sao bởi vì à à
từ khóa chính cũng giống như ở cái trả
lời luôn cột người này là là cột bà còn
nên có cột mã và thận chữa để nó tự động
tăng 20
hóa chính thì nên là số thì nó nhẹ nhất
để nó nấu ra mà khác không nên để nó chữ
rồi nói ra mà khác nó nặng hơn đấy Cái
thứ nhất thứ hai là
các bạn là
về việc để phân biệt hàng ngày với thằng
kia các bạn thường ai có truyền theo mã
để mà sửa xóa thằng nào đó chỉ việc mạn
hay vì truyền mã Các bạn truyền Email
thì sửa hàng nào đó thì mình thấy bài
toán nó trong nó vẻ phức tạp hơn các bạn
nên chỉ truyền mã thì nó sửa xem thêm
sửa xóa thằng nào đó hơn hơn là truyền
email dễ thương lắm mã này có thể số thì
đúng hoặc à đoạn chuỗi theo kiểu là
Uruguay đi chơi thường là chẳng ai nó
kiểu truyền truyền email treo để nó
xưởng cái gì đó gà nên nó thành vô lý
đúng ạ Các bạn thấy chẳng thằng nào làm
từ điều đấy khác đâu chị ạ ạ
A và bảng nào cũng có cần cột mã tự động
tăng hay không thì ra là không
sau khi mà các bạn muốn thêm sửa xóa à
muốn nối nó sang thẳng bản khác thì có
bạn mới có cột cần Còn mã tự động tăng
anh còn không thì gần như các bạn sẽ
không cần cột Mã làm gì cả trừ khi ở cậu
các bạn muốn sửa nó dễ và không có cột
nào của tunick thôi Bây giờ thì mình thử
Ví dụ nhé Có bạn hóa đơn chi tiết
các bạn nhiều nó sẽ có mã hóa đơn này và
mã sản phẩm
và số lượng hôm trước cũng có bạn ốp
thêm cả cuộn Mã từ đóng băng ở đây nữa
Mình thấy được ra cột này nó chả mơ nối
đến đâu ạ mà chẳng để làm gì cả các bạn
để mà biết tiền lấy ra được cái hóa đơn
thì ra các bạn lấy theo mã hóa đơn không
ạ lấy ra hóa đơn kèm sản phẩm của bạn sẽ
dựa theo hai cục này hay cột này cũng là
khóa chính luôn được chưa Thế là chẳng
cần cột mã tự đóng băng làm gì cả
ừ ừ
thì các bạn đừng có bị Rập khuôn là bảo
nào cũng cần mã cột mã tự động đăng nhé
bây giờ đấy
hôm mình đang trả lời rất nhiều câu mà
Thậm chí à hôm bảo vệ đồ án tôi sẽ hỏi
cho tôi tôi sẽ có hỏi cả lý thuyết và
thực hành nhé thực hành là nói về bài
toán về cốt và về cách giải quyết vấn đề
và cách xử lý vấn đề
cho con về lý thuyết thế là tôi hỏi
những cái này đâu ạ Đây tôi mà đã dậy
Cái gì Tôi luôn nhớ là tôi đã dạy cho
đến rồi tôi hỏi mấy ông mà mấy hôm trời
được thì đương nhiên với ông Định trừ
điểm không ạ Có đấy nhá Ừ
a Tiếp theo là cái cái Các bạn nhớ mình
từng nói các bạn viết tài liệu ông ạ sẽ
mình sẽ cho các bạn xem lại cái tài liệu
có một cái bản tài liệu nó đầy đủ thì nó
sẽ làm như thế nào
em gái mình sẽ cho các bạn xem
từ nãy giờ mình vẫn đang vừa trả lời vừa
dậy luôn đấy nhá Không không không bảo
mình tính thời gian cứ thư được đây mình
sẽ có cái tài liệu mẫu
Em không biết đấy Đúng là liệu mẫu nhỉ
anh ở đây đây đúng không có tài liệu mẫu
sẽ bia hôm đấy bọn tôi tôi yêu cầu mới
hoang y này nữa em phải có bia
Khi ra về sau các bạn cũng nên có mấy
bia rượu trong Nghệ sĩ không ạ
I lời mở đầu này
cách móc hoa giới thiệu đưa ra vấn đề
anh về sau kể từ rồi sẽ nhắc lại này để
ông làm tài liệu mà nhưng tớ nói qua đã
giới thiệu chung về dự án xuất xứ dự án
Lý do cận hình giao tạo dự án đấy hệ
thống hiện tại Đức à trước khi có dự án
này trước khi làm ra các phần mềm này
thì bản chất mình đã làm gì Ví dụ là sử
trước này trước khi có cái trang web bán
hàng bán hàng này thì chị có bán hàng
trực tiếp không bán hàng online cả không
ạ Đấy số 10 lưu lại thông tin qua Excel
Word hoặc lưu lại trên giấy nó ngoạn đó
sau đó Thì bây giờ mình sẽ cần làm ra
một cái sản phẩm như thế nào yêu cầu gì
Yêu cầu chạy được trên ie không Vân Vân
Vân yêu cầu như thế nào đúng ạ Vì rõ hết
ra công nghệ mình áp dụng lần này sẽ là
gì đấy phân tích này Phân tích khi trước
Nam giữa các phím chức năng không phải
một tính năng gì đó ví dụ Giả sử là giao
diện bắt mắt này giao diện trụ To 20 cho
người già cho sạch trẻ con Ừ mẹ không
dùng dùng được trên kiểu máy hệ điều
hành Windows 20 V.League P20 chẳng hạn
thế Vân không ạ ừ ừ
ở nhóm người sử dụng loại
khách hàng chưa tay có tài khoản làm
được J có tài khoản làm cái gì cái không
trước nói rồi sau đó phân tích Chức Nam
thì chức năng này cái thứ mà mình đang
định nói ở đây chính là cái này đó là
các bạn phải liệt kê rõ toàn bộ là
ai là người ví dụ đăng nhập ở lại Ai là
người có thể làm được cái nói chung
hướng sử dụng được chức năng này không ạ
mô tả này chúng mang này nó làm gì à
khi kích hoạt khi bấm ở đâu đấy nó sẽ
kích hoạt tổ chức năng này đầu và là
những cái thước của người đăng nhập từ
bàn phím và bảo hiểm tràn ngập những cái
gì đó trình tự xử lý nó là gì Lấy lấy
cái thông tin gì gì đó về virus ung thư
sau đó kết nối cơ sở liệu đóng gói thì
kiểm tra xem khớp hay không khớp thì cho
vào không đi giao đầu ra thì hiển thị
Đúng là gì sai là gì đấy lưu ý ạ Đây huy
những cái gì Cái này nó là văn xuôi
không phải Cốt nó là nhưng cần như tôi
thấy nó mã ra để mà các bạn nhìn ở đây
các bạn cốt được cái thường hay được
viết Ừ để cho dân
vì dân không phải dân công nghệ đọc
Ừ cái tài liệu này không phải là dân
công nghệ đọc vẫn phải hiểu được Thế em
làm mấy ông không được viết tắt cũng đi
là không được viết
Ừ
từ chuyên ngành mấy ở trong này phải
biết sao cho dân không phải dân công
nghệ đọc Tại sao cái này vừa là tài liệu
để mà tham khảo để mà gửi cho bất kỳ ai
vừa mới vào công ty các bạn có thể đọc
qua để thiệu qua được cái phần mềm các
bạn đang làm là là gì và giao cho ông
công việc kiểu ôm làm tính năng này
không nhìn vào cái ông hiểu được phần mô
tả thì mấy ông có được cũng như là cái
này mấy ông xem sắp tang cho biết qua về
mấy cái vụ kia lên để mặc cái gọi vốn
không ạ
Cái này thì cũng là cái in tài liệu ra
để cho mẹ ông mấy ông ở trên kia đọc đầu
nhọn mà hình dung qua được là sản phẩm
Ông nó nó như thế nào Có cần phải làm
những cái gì
Vì thế nên là nghĩa là không phải dân
trong ngành đọc cũng phải hiểu được
không ạ Và nó chúng ở hôm buổi bảo vệ đồ
nó đúng là như thế đó mới không phải
thuyết phục được người kia cảm thấy sản
phẩm của ông đánh này là Ừ kệ bản chất ở
tài liệu là hết thứ nhất là phải có
trước cái phần mềm để mà cái người cái
người kiểu giặc sư giám đốc đi đêm em
cái hình dung ngay nhé mày ông đang định
làm một cái
chạm một cái trang web một cái phần mềm
mấy ông Nghĩa phải mất nửa Nam và cần
đầu tư vậy cũng tầm
gần tỷ 300 triệu gì gì đó để làm phần
mềm mấy người tốn thời gian thôi nhưng
tốn kém các thử thứ thì ông sẽ làm tài
liệu này là mày ông dễ làm một cái sản
phẩm để môi trước để mà
đưa lên thuyết trình cho giám đốc hoặc
cả nói cho Hoa cấp trên là ngọn để cấp
chân chính cấp trên duyệt sau đó cấp rên
trên mày đưa tiền mới rót vốn vào để đầu
tư để mà làm sản phẩm chứ không phải mấy
ông làm phần một sản phẩm hoàn Trinh
ở sông lý thuyết trình ra ai chẳng ai
hiểu sản phẩm mấy đâu và là sự người ta
không tốt 4 và thịnh mấy ông chết à
không ạ Nếu ông bỏ thôi thời gian công
sức ra người ta không duyệt thì dao động
ngoại Thế nên là đều phải có tài liệu
đầy đủ cũng như là mấy ông phải làm các
sản phẩm demo một cách tương đối thôi
cũng được để mấy ông đem đi trên Đông ạ
Cái bảo vệ đồ án này đương nhiên là sản
phẩm đấy mộ sẽ ăn đấy sản phẩm đến mô
rồi bởi vì sản phẩm của ông là mong hai
tháng chẳng có ai dung được nó còn đầy
lỗi đầy thứ cần phải làm nữa nhưng người
ra thấy là
vì nó có tiềm năng nó có triển vọng nó
bán đáng để đầu tư vào thì họ sẽ đầu tư
ông ạ Thế nên là cái cái tài liệu này
cũng như là phải sản phẩm demo của ông
phải phải tương đối và tương đối ôn ông
ạ và phải dễ hiểu về chưa chứ trình của
mấy ông phải dễ hiểu bởi Nếu nó kêu gọi
vốn mà Mấy ông nói thì được
sản phẩm của em thợ sơ sài lắm chả có
cái gì đâu hơn dân thì chả ngay dốc muốn
ôm cả không ạ Đấy Nói chung là không bảo
vệ đồ án thì mấy ông cũng xem nhiều sắp
anh mà mình không học dần đi đứng nhà
tôi không muốn họ bảo mấy ông phải báo
cáo thống kê được các báo cáo với tài
chính không nghe máy không phải
Ừ biết biết cách thuyết trình ở ngoại ô
ai biết cách thuyết phục người khác
ý nghĩa của tài liệu như thế thế nên là
mấy ông đừng có viết tài liệu theo kiểu
mình ông lọc được nhé cái tài liệu này
không phải ông làm ra để ngày này năm
xong xem lại đâu nhé Đây liệu này viết
ra để cho người khác đọc nhưng mà Mấy
ông phải viết sao cho nó tim mì nó nó
chi tiết ý kỹ tính và đi để ngoại hôm
trước tôi xem Khánh Như của nhóm say
mình lỗi chính tả nỗi buồn lắm nhưng
không phải học lại cách viết code đi
à à
a tiếp theo các bạn bị Cái lỗi này thật
ra mình không biết được Cái lỗi này
Nhưng mà mình cứ để cho các bạn tự trải
nghiệm đã một mình mới bắt đầu chữa Cái
lỗi này là khi các bạn à
Sistar thận thì các bạn lỗ sự tác ở
trong cái file menu rồi các bạn ở trên ở
pha bình thường các bạn đã Sinh tát rồi
trong file menu các bạn restart lại phát
nữa nếu bạn include the famine vào xảy
ra nó Sistar tận 23 lần gì đó khá nhanh
nó lỗi thì cách đơn giản ở đây mình có
đề cập đó là các bạn chỉ nên xét phát ở
ngay cái file đầu tiên và Không chèn xây
dựng Tát ở ở những cái file mà mình sẽ
in Plus là sự file crack này thì các
loại stop ngay đâu nè ở đó dưới này các
bạn nút vào thì chẳng mới đề gì à các
bạn đừng có Sinh tát ở trong này trong
này hay trong mai đúng ạ Các bạn xin xác
mỗi trên cùng như này thôi của một cái
file chính đều không ạ thì nó sẽ không
lỗi và cái bài toán ở đây thì mình có
nói đó là em
có bạn thì bảo là em sẽ ít theo ở kiểm
tra xem đó xin sát hay chưa ở trong từng
file này cũng được được nhà cái đấy hỡi
kỵ tinh quá và thực ra về sau mình cũng
không làm theo mô hình hưởng rộng rãi mà
trẻ hết mình đóng vai lằng nhằng nhưng
ai trong nói dối các bạn sẽ không biết
được là file này đang chứa gì file kia
chứ gì là 1 thì mình sẽ tách nó ra mô
hình mvc và vì sao còn theo phương Quốc
nữa thì các bạn không cần phải lo việc
được các bạn phải hiểu quá rõ về mấy cái
mấy cái kiểu tách ghép file như này về
sau có mô hình nó làm hết rồi các bạn
này các bạn không cần phải
chuyên sâu này quá nên mình đang chị dậy
tương đối là các bạn mẹo các bạn ạ Bạn
cứ start ở mỗi trên trang mỗi file chính
rồi cũng phải nốt điều mơ dịch sữa Smart
là được à
em có bạn hỏi nữa mình trả lời nhanh đó
mà có bạn hỏi là crack ở đâu ổn ra sự
crack Office hóa crack win thì mẹ từng
nói đó là các bạn lên Facebook các bạn
tìm một cái nhóm là kích hoạt
khi kích hoạt bản quyền
kế hoạch Office hoặc kích hoạt Windows
dưới đó có rất nhiều nhóm và chuyện
Facebook như thế thì như là lượng người
thiện nguyện lượng người tham gia chỉ có
tầm 20 mệnh hay mấy nghìn người thôi nhớ
thấy đã nhưng mà nhỏ mẹ đi tí mình mấy
lần lên đấy ý chỉ cần đăng đăng mà cậu
các bạn nên đang theo cú pháp như thế
này nhá Nếu mà các bạn xem cái Bài ghim
người ra rồi thì các bạn kiểu còn không
thì các bạn cứ làm cú pháp nó ra Kiểu
nhớ là các bạn phải xem được là
Em đừng có lên đang đúng một câu lục đó
hả ai đó kích hoạt Win hộ em chấm hết
Hình như bài sẽ không mua được rồi vì
hỏi không vô tâm được hỏi có dâm ở như
nào các bạn sẽ phải Vào setting để xem
được là
hệ điều hành các bạn Win bao nhiêu cái
thứ nhất nhì thế ngoạn là sự như thế này
vào xem được Kiểu các bạn dùng Win mấy
đây
rồi nha Win 10 pro này version mấy này
đã khá nhìn này đi nhân như thế Office
các bạn như thế bạn phải nói cụ thể là
các bạn sẽ không
sử dụng Office phiên bản bao nhiêu Vân
Vân Đấy đấy Cái thứ nhất nhé thứ hai đó
là sẽ có một người sẽ bà là các bạn
inbox cho họ
thì các bạn đừng bao giờ lên à
cho nên a kiểu gửi luôn cái tivi ở trên
trang ở trên cái bài đang đấy vì ai Nếu
Thế lại vào được tivi các bạn thì chết
các bạn nên kiểu ý nhắn qua inbox và các
bạn còn đến xem lại và các bạn ấn bấm mà
luôn nick người kia để nó xem qua người
kia hoạt động thế nào ở trong nhà nhóm
đấy cuộc sống nổi không Bởi vì có nhiều
người thì đúng là vào đấy là mà lừa ai
đó trên view vào khách máy này ra
Ừ thì các bạn hãy xem xem người đấy Có
ổn hay không Hãy gửi teamview sao về đây
người bị hack qua teamview rồi đấy mày
không Thế nên tôi mới bảo là mày ông
crack Xong rồi ông cũng thương hay dẫn
lên có vấn đề gì đó con thường là mấy về
anh kia kiểu teamview qua làm việc
chuyên nghiệp hết mình thấy chị 23 phút
thôi là crack xong 10 là crack Đông mình
đã kích hoạt thi cho mình đấy hoặc đi
bằng điều gì mình không rõ lắm kích hoạt
cho mình đấy bây giờ không crack cho
mình đâu ngờ cái hoạt này có vẻ vĩnh
viễn gì vậy Mình mình cứ mỗi lần mình ở
xong lại đi rằng là nó ổn vài năm sau A
a tiếp theo học ở trang nào cũng kết nối
đoàn tàu bay Có vấn đề gì không ra thì
về sau các bạn sẽ biết được mà
Ừ thứ nhất ở đó nhưng kết nối nhiều nó
sẽ sẵn ở không ổn thôi nhe thế không ổn
rồi nhưng là thực tế là vì sau ở trang
nào cũng lấy dữ liệu ra mà cũng mặc kiểu
định phải kết nối nên các bạn về sau nếu
tìm hiểu kỹ hơn về các bạn sẽ biết rất
nhiều cách để hạn chế điều này làm như
lưu lại đây lại cách để mà giảm thiểu
cho cái nối này hơn vân vân vân Thế mình
sẽ dạy kỹ hơn sau còn bây giờ hiện tại
thì các bạn làm như mình làm đó là Mở
kết nối nhờ nhờ đóng cái nỗi nhớ để cái
thứ nhất thứ hai các bạn nghĩ rằng làm
việc là tôi yêu cầu truy vấn cho bớt
truy vấn thôi cũng được cũng được rồi
phim hoạt hình làm mịn quá Hôm nay bắt
đầu bây giờ bắt đầu học nha là màn bao
giờ nó có ok
Ừ ok ở đây thì mình hôm nay mình sẽ dạy
các bạn về hôm trước làm cái giỏ hàng
rồi nghỉ à
à à
Em
đổi tên rồi
web cơ bản à
Ừ đúng rồi bị đội tên miền này là mất ít
hơn nữa vào đăng nhập lại vậy thì mới ở
trước hết đăng nhập lại thì vừa mình cho
các bạn xem lại tao bay mình phải sửa
jambe một tí Bởi vì lần này mình sẽ lưu
lại thông tin của khách hàng ở trong
trong bạc khách hàng để mà tí mình bảo
hành mình chỉ cần lấy thông tin này ra
tự động điện nó sẽ dễ hơn khi mà khách
hàng đăng ký rồi khách hàng ở mất công
nghiệp địa chỉ rồi thì lần sau mình phải
lấy lại địa chỉ cũ gái hàng đã nhập để
mà dùng tránh việc bắt khách hàng nhập
niệm loại nó dỗi nó không vì nó không
đặt lại nữa hãy khó chịu ra
Ừ tôi từng thế
em có nhiều Trang nó khó chịu đúng kiểu
như thế luôn Thế là sao mẹ đặt mỗi pizza
tắt Đăng ký xong rồi đăng ký xong vẫn
gọi điện lại thông tin mình vừa lại vừa
nhập đăng ký
UC vãi
ô nhiễm đường như thế
Tôi tin là chắc chắn ở sinh viên của tôi
Cậu gì về sau cũng sẽ làm một ngày trang
web gì đó Tôi không muốn về Sao tới động
là đúng những cây xăng web đấy mà Mấy
ông lại gây khó chịu người dùng
buồn lắm
ở chỗ nào Nhưng cái cốt đấy những cái
cốt rất là dễ luôn đấy chồng ạ Nhưng nếu
không ở những người dùng mới không
thương người dùng không thương người
dùng thì ghen à
Ê mấy ông mà làm cái á
Ừ
đúng rồi thưởng các cấp các bạn đăng ký
đặt hàng thì các bạn vẫn để điền thông
tin người nhận là người khác có nhưng mà
các bạn nên tự nên là có kén nút một là
nút ở Ấn và tích là sẽ tự động điền
thông tin mình đã đăng nhập này hòa tự
động Điền chiếu cũng được người dùng thả
xóa đi để Điệp lại trải nghiệm dùng một
tốt hơn việc là người dùng cứ thấy mình
vừa Điền xong thông tin lại bắt buộc
phải điền lên thông tin nữa khó chịu cực
Ừ cái đây trải nghiệm người dùng không
tốt đâu cứ khẳng định luôn cái á
một số người bỏ bỏ về đơn đấy
anh chủ yếu là lúc mà khi người ta đến
mức cô ấy người ta không phải bước cuối
thanh toán đâu bước cuối người ta đến
thông tin về à Cái thời gian đấy người
ta thường ngày lưỡng hợp nhất để bỏ cái
đơn thôi Nếu mà làm cho người ta khó
chịu lúc đấy là người ta sẽ luôn Bỏ đơn
Nếu ông mặt thống kê cái vụ đơn đã bị bỏ
đi tỷ lệ thấp Cực
nhà tỷ lệ thành công thấp quý Tôi làm ở
trên trang web là bán hàng đôi biết mà
Lợi chị hai ba phần trăm nữa là cao ấy
rất là cao ấy nhiều chả không đến cơ à
ờ ờ
có thêm thông tin mà ngon
số
[âm nhạc]
phận mình lại chưa
Ê con chó rất mình là nó cứ sủa mà nó
xuôi mình lại giận mình theo ý
à à
à
À quên One để tiếng Anh à phone number
nóng lạnh ạ
à à
anh không Nó sủa nó mà sửa cái tiếng
động lạ thì thôi không đánh nó nó 1 xổ
con mèo chỗ rách thì tôi sẽ này ngon
ờ ờ địa chỉ address à
chú chó nhắc Hôm nay đánh
Ô Ôu bao giờ tôi đang dùng cái mic thu
hái ngạnh có để mức mắc cả vô lu bu
Ý anh là mấy ông tôi ngay cái gì mày Ông
cố Thế nghe vậy gấp đôi tôi nghĩa về để
trải nghiệm công việc tốt giá
Bphone đăng ký không ạ
thì mình sẽ có đã sai hát này
chị sẽ có mật khẩu à
cho
số điện thoại
or number
địa chỉ và có để tách nữa cho họ tách
alo thôi Nói đùa thôi thường Mấy ông
không nhập địa chỉ xuống làm đâu ạ
thì ra tất cả không cần các bạn bị pha
tra được thôi để tách cả được là hơi
nhiều quá
Chưa chết nổ Nội để chị nhà mới rồi
không đi đâu mèo không không thấy gì nhé
tôi mở lại gần rang nha
các mẹ Đấy nó hiển thị cái nhỉ
Mấy ông đừng đốt nhé Đây là ngõ rồi mày
Ông đốt nhầm nhà đấy
à mật khẩu 123 đi
ừ ừ
chị đã lẽ là tôi có thể dùng cái nick
khác thì sẽ không có lộ mới thông tin nó
đề xuất ra thôi kể chắc sinh viên Trang
toàn sinh viên xem mà không có ông nào
ghét tôi mà ngồi xem mấy đâu đúng không
ạ
Ừ cái báo lỗi
báo lỗi vì À đây mẹ sang xem Tại sao Nó
lỗi
cái bản chất là khi mình đến này Ok này
ổn rồi này Nhưng khi mình Insert xong
rồi mình lấy lại thông tin thì nó bị lỗi
còn gì ở rõ là ý shop mình có vấn đề
mình chắc chắn là như thế vì rõ là chiếu
cột mà nó ngoại gì chứ vấn đề rồi đấy
mình sẽ thêm là phần nằm mơ này I
à à
ăn xong tôi không sợ chồng như anh Tuấn
đâu anh Tuấn kiểu ẩn danh hoàn toàn thôi
chứ ra mấy ông Nếu mà không thực sự mà
ghét một ai đó tôi nói thẳng là kiểu thư
da là nếu có thể tra nhiều cách mà cha
không ra được thông tin từ chính cái
thằng đấy là sự thật này không đăng
thông tin lên thì ra là người ông thấy
ví dụ chiến tranh là nhất mà thôi có mẹ
có tác thôi thường xuyên là nặng Nếu
không tra theo là lớn lớn hơn đường ai
cũng sai tất cả thứ trên Facebook không
lại thăm chị em mấy ông có thể tạo một
cái nick kiểu nick của bạn là người lớn
đấy Có ảnh đại diện của bạn lớn đấy sợ
tên giống hệt cản sau đây cũng lặp lại
nick rồi bà Lạt sao kết bạn lại với với
người người lớn đấy đúng không Sao lại
bỏ đó Nick mới bị hack mà vẫn không
không hỏi kiểu dáng nhờ chuyển tiền thì
cứ hư đâu mà Mấy ông chỉ cần bà kìa
Dạo này thằng thằng Long dạo này thế nào
cả nạn đúng ạ à
máy cạo râu không gặp đó thôi giặt giờ
khỏi thăm nó cứ rồi bạn hẹn à Bây giờ
nhà nó đang ở đâu rồi Nãy giờ xử thế giờ
hết thông tin à
Ừ cái đấy gọi social Engineering đấy là
thí nghệ xã hội Em bé uống sữa đã hack
não người già chứ không lẽ Hack bằng
công nghệ mình nếu không sẽ lừa thường
người lớn người ta nhẹ dạ cả tin lắm
Tôi nói đúng không Sao sai được thì
không hệ Đúng rồi à quên quên quên mình
sẽ lấy lại hai cái này
gì
hả ông bảo ông không kết bạn người thân
à
ông chết đàn ông các bạn bè lắm thế thôi
chứ khi ông Kiểu ni kiểu Clone ông không
kết bạn bạn bè không liên quan bất kỳ ai
hết thì chị
à à
anh không báo lỗi gì cả trong với vẻ dù
thử xem nhé
ừ ừ
ở đó ra rồi này ông ngoại ra cái địa chỉ
nhà mình đây này đại khái như thế Ok Bây
giờ sửa quay lại bên bên này đặt thự mua
sắm sản phẩm nó không ạ
nhà máy sản phẩm trên chả khác biệt
Nhưng tôi chỉ đặt những sản phẩm trong
người phát hiện nhé
đỏ như thế này nó sự có 2 sản phẩm đây
là các bạn nên khó cái nút ở khi mà ở
đây sẽ có nút là kiểu và không phải mỗi
lúc đăng xuất nữa đúng không Xem giỏ
hàng thì lại cái thế không ạ Các bạn sẽ
ra sẽ chở hàng ở đây chẳng hạn
I
love you kept này à
khi
tăng số lượng lên ngoại
Ừ thì ah bây giờ mình sẽ có nút đặt hàng
ở dưới nhưng mà kèm theo điền thông tin
người nhận nữa sao nó có thêm tổng tiền
đấy đã có nút xóa giỏ hàng đấy nữa Ừ
ngon thì đầu tiên cái tổng tiền ý đầu
tiên mình hiển thị Cẩm Tiên đã thì cái
cách để lấy tổng tiền được ra nó dễ thôi
đầu tiên là mình cứ trước vòng lọc mình
cho
dụ là săn ăn bằng không ạ sau đó trong
vòng lặp này mình sẽ xăm xăm bằng cái
này đúng ạ nó sẽ như thế này
anh
ở đây nó là
ở đây sẽ là kẻ vi rút đi đi sút bằng
nhờ các cụ này
xăm cộng bằng vi sốt
ở đây là bản chất mình in lại virus ra
thôi
em xăm cậu bằng lấy sốt mà Thôi kết thúc
kể thuê bồ mình sẽ có đây à tổng tiền
hóa đơn này
sẽ làm cho đồ ra săm là xong thì chuyện
đô la lần trước cho mẹ chồng nhiều tiền
như này ngoại t.ư
Ừ đúng nhỉ đúng lúc Ok mà máy tính tính
nữa rọi mình tính rồi sẽ đúng đấy
Ok thì bây giờ mình sẽ điền thông tin ở
đây thì bản chất điền thông tin nó cái
form nó không ạ sẽ có bom này à
thì mình sẽ điện à tên người nhận này
phút đây đi sẽ tách này à
thì mình sẽ là hình sẽ bây giờ mình phải
tạo ra ta bây đã đóng loa mình sẽ tạo ra
tao bay trước đã mình sẽ có hóa đơn chi
tiết thì ok ở đây mang hóa đơn số lượng
tôi đẩy xuống dưới này đấy thì ở đây sẽ
có bảo Hóa đơn đã hóa đơn này mình sẽ
gồm những gì mình sẽ của mã này mà khách
hàng
có tên người nhận là đường ngoại tên
người nhận
số điện thoại người nhận
địa chỉ người nhận
trạng thái trạng thái đơn là kiểu
mới đặt nó nhọn đã hoàn thành đã hủy gì
đó
thời gian đặt ạ ạ
Ừ đấy đại khái nhất là phải cơ bản những
cái kiểu như thế này không ạ thì lại tên
người nhận đi sẽ là
nên VSIP Ơ
không rõ tiếng anh ngắm tí Supper seat
Ừ vợ
ấy mẹo để mạng tra tiếng Anh nhanh đấy
số điện thoại người nhận
mình tôi nên chia sẻ nếu uống hơi nhiều
mẹ mày tranh này nên đặt tên đội lại mẹo
vặt chấm com
ừ ừ
Ừ
anh sẽ là đặt hàng à
khi hết pin Arsenal ở Việt Nam Á
ở Phú phết nhỉ
con gà nó vô set.tre cao đấy Đặt hàng mà
à
Ừ ok à
Ừ nó sau đó thì mình phải thấy cái đây
đã nghỉ thì chả là bây giờ
chị sẽ hóa đơn này đây sẽ có
à à
thứ bảy cụt
Có ai đi nè
xe Honda
Mỹ Tâm em
ID này
ờ ờ
a
neves shipper
for Transfer
HP shipper status ở
Ừ cái này là
ừ ừ
ở
thời gian đặt có thể thời gian tạo được
rất ít
đường này đặt ngay sau chuẩn nào chưa
cài đặt như này
cho mình cái này một là mình dùng Mà
thường Lưu lại theo kiểu một là đến ham
hai thăm xem từ các bạn ạ hết ham thì
các bạn nhìn thấy ở đây nó sẽ là ngày
tháng năm giờ phút giây còn cái tham
stem này thì nó cũng kiểu như thế nhưng
mà nó theo dạng là số dây từ năm 1970
đến hiện tại thì cái số dây này đôi khi
nó hợp lý là điểm mà là mình dùng cái
hàm convert để đổi nó sang thứ Hiển mì
hiển thị mình mong muốn cũng được hoặc
cả cái này nó đến ham thì các bạn in ra
luôn thì trong nó cũng cũng đọc được
nhưng mỗi tội là nhiều người không thích
bị in ra luôn nó ngày tháng năm giờ phút
giây mình hẹn thường ai đọc nó là À nhầm
năm tháng ngày giờ phút giây mình đọc
thường ngày tháng năm hơn không ạ ạ
Ô thế Mình nghĩ là các bạn nên chuyển
qua dần một cái thang tap nhiều nơi
thằng này dùng tham step hơn
ạ sau đó thì con bớt nào Theo hiển thị
theo thứ mình muốn thì nó hợp lý hơn
Ừ cái này để tách này nhà để cha
U20 này
có ai
k50id à
tự động Ai đi tự động tăng cái xát Ớt
này mình sẽ để quy ước nó không là 15
thẳng cái gì đó dạng số rồi sau đó mình
cứ vừa là hàng cốt được và các bạn tách
hẳn dựa riêng em bạn nhưng mình nói ta
các bạn nào nếu mà có nhiều sao tốt hơn
mà các bạn muốn gửi cho chỉnh sửa sau
Tết thì các bạn tách hẳn ra riêng thận
bạn sẽ tốt nhé
thì
mình sẽ đây sẽ có bảo hóa đơn Chi tiết
nữa
chợ hoa cà thường là các bạn một là hóa
đơn chi tiết đời thiếu hay các bạn có
thể đặt khi mà một bảng trung gian giữa
2 3
bảng này chúng là Node phố đắt thì các
bạn thể đặt tên nó nó đầu của đắt cũng
được như này cách để mà là tên mạng này
Tại sao không phải bố decoder mà oder
của đắp mà thường là nó sẽ đặt tên thứ
nhất là không phải do bạn nào sinh ra
trước bạn nào mà theo bạn theo khi bạn
trung gian như thế này nó thường này
theo bạn theo ạ xót thêm là chữ cái chứ
nào làm năng trước thì đã lên đâu Kiểu
như này bởi vì ví dụ là sự là bảng này
trung gian giữa lớp sơn mờ với nhau rồi
em ạ Nó sẽ cố trong màu áo đồ cho mày
order customer kiểu như thế à các bạn sẽ
gồm 3 cột
chị sẽ là họ đờ ID
customer ID
Anh tên tên Mạnh trước này tôi về dưới
rồi ai đi lại trong nhà dễ hiểu còn tin
à
anh lại không có cô nào tự động tăng đấy
đâu nhá lưu lại này và riêng cái này thì
à nhưng mình nói aid mình mình sửa bên
order trước nhé riêng mình thì mình có
cột nối cốt 10 đi mình phải nói đến bạn
có xâm Mau mình sẽ bridgeview này hoa
Các bạn nhớ về câu truy vấn trong SQL để
tạo khói mãi không ạ Các bạn sử dụng
enter để có bạn sửa còn đây mình đang sợ
bằng tool thì các bạn thấy vậy dễ hơn
mình sẽ chọn là tôi sẽ 10 đi mình sẽ nối
đến cơ sở Mơ này nó sẽ tự động resort
các bạn có cột nào Có thể nối thường là
cô tự động tăng này thôi hỏi của email
nhưng mình nói email nó unique nên nó
được đề xuất giờ chẳng ai nối rồi đấy cả
sẽ nối với cậu Út khóa chính thôi
a tiếp theo and therefore thứ nhất là
trước khi nổi trước khi nổi nhá thì các
bạn sẽ phải tạo nó khai khóa chính thức
đã
à à khi tạ bạc tình yêu mình chọn được
quả chính vì vậy những quên mất nó giả
sử lỡ tạm rồi thì các bạn sẽ có ăn khái
niệm enter table này app Viber kia này
Make Me Đỏ Chắc ở nhà
Xin chào không dưỡng đấy bạn sẽ có
ch3 Mickey này
nó thì với bạn order của đất nước ạ
Chị sẽ có 2 cột khóa chính nó còn Oh
Daddy và cơ sở 10 đi
vì mình đã từng mình từng rảnh qua về
cái vụ ạ Tại sao hai con này khóa chính
rồi nhé nhưng mình không nhớ nó video ở
đâu này các bạn rồi các bạn là nào mới
xe mày có bạn phải xem lại từ đầu đến
cuối đấy Đúng rồi mình khó mà lưu lại
từng cái mục nhỏ một lắm và sự không có
thời gian làm tất cả những điều đấy
em về mình sẽ nối khóa ngoại này
anh một cái
anh nói khoác ngoài để ràng buộc thôi
chức ra nó cũng không ạ Tại sao cô cho
mới đi đấy Thôi xong tôi nhầm rồi
Cái phải để nó là Bố đặt cái đi Anh nhớ
hình như nãy giờ ngủ gật thì phải mấy
ông chặn Nhắc tôi cả đậu xanh
anh alo ngủ hết rồi đúng không
phụ nữ yêu khám phá thấy nguội à
Khi hết giờ rồi
anh alo đâu hết rồi Kiểm tra đồ hết rồi
ừ ừ
Ừ nếu có gì nhắc rồi à mình tao ngồi
nghe nghe thế kiểu đang đợi đến giây
phút quấy để chia sẻ gì đó rồi
Ừ
Thế mấy ông thầy tôi say con này nhắc
lại cả đậu xanh tôi cố tình xa đấy
vì nó không anh em là nhắc thôi Tôi buồn
quá
hai
lúa cái đoạn đấy có gì luôn đó tôi nói
chậm mà thế Chứng tỏ ông vừa nghe Em
buồn ngủ rồi
ừ ừ
anh
nói chung là bây giờ mình mình cần điền
toàn bộ Nếu phải tương tác nào mày mày
không buồn ngủ còn không thì mấy ông
nghe nhưng nghe giảng đạo mấy cũng chẳng
buồn ngủ
ừ ừ
à à Bạn bị Xem thầy cô để bài giảng
không ạ Hay
anh giống như kẹo Tại sao thể dạng trong
khi em đang buồn ngủ đúng không Thế lỗi
rồi thầy ạ
anh nói chung à Ok thì bây giờ mình cần
lấy toàn bộ những cái điên trong form ở
ngọn
Ừ
nhưng mà không phải mỗi thế mà Bởi vì a
mình cần là này nó khó hơn tận thế mất
cả bộ Hôm nay chị vừa nó nó yêu sớm nó
hỏi rất giận 23 nó order vào đồ đắt
ngoại thì bây giờ để để tôi nói không
hỏi mấy ông mà Mấy ông đi ngủ nhé em
xe máy béo nhìn kỹ lại ở bên này
Ừ nó nhìn lại cái Trang
Trang do hàng đầu đúng không Thì mấy ông
nó lại rồi đó là bây giờ khi mình đi rớt
vào thì mình phải in rất là bao nhiêu
bạn và ờ
I Insert vào bao nhiêu Bảng và mỗi bảng
đấy có bao nhiêu bạn đi Thiên xuất và
a research
vào bao nhiêu bạn ạ
ở mỗi bảng
sẽ có bao nhiêu bạn đi ừ
hình ảnh
ở đây là cái hôm đặt hàng của tôi không
ạ
khi cha cha trả lời trả lời trả lời à
em trả lời tình ngủ nữa
Ừ tự nhiên ông kia hỏi về Unity vậy thôi
Chả biết Unity cái gì cơ
À có rồi ông ấy thấy chứng rõ mày ngủ
gật rồi mẹ vợ tôi kết nối nối khóa mà
hết rồi
em
trả lời trả lời nào Alo
anh nói 90 ông rồi cũng
b8200 kia ngủ luôn đó
bà bà
để đáp án ở giờ rồi
cho muối vào mùa bạn đi thế cũng là giờ
rồi
rất nhiều bạn nhiều bạn là cái gì
em không ở đây có cụ thể đấy
sau khi mình đặt hàng nhé mình sẽ usopp
vào bao nhiêu Ba Đó là những bản à Nói
rõ ra đó là những bảng nào
và mỗi vàng sẽ có bao nhiêu bạn ghi cụ
thể mỗi bạn không ạ
bà cụ thể
mỗi bạc sẽ có bao nhiêu bạn đi
U23 order 1 order Black n bạn chưa nói
có đúng không ạ phải thế mới chuẩn em
Thực ra cụ thể ở đây không phải đâu nó
lấy có mỗi hai sản phẩm thôi nó sẽ chỉ
giữa hai bản ghi thôi ông ạ
à à
anh nói sốt 2 bạn nó là bảng order Đông
ạ order cô đắt bạn order thì mình chỉ
đến suốt một bạn ghi đó mình tạo một hóa
đơn thôi không ạ một hóa đơn thôi nhưng
mà một hóa đơn này sẽ có nhiều sản phẩm
đông lạnh có 2 sản phẩm bị tất cả có hai
bạn ghi bởi vì nó sẽ ra mã hóa đơn là
cái mình sẽ lại đây thôi ông ạ Mình sẽ
Insert đấy có mã là một mã hoặc mã hóa
đơn là một Nhưng mình có tận 2 sản phẩm
sản phẩm Một và sản phẩm hay là em ạ sẽ
lặp lại như thế này không ạ xong nó lấy
đúng với số lượng đã đặt như thế này
Insert và ngoại 31 nha Chừng nào ông ạ
Thế thôi
Ê mày ông Vợ nhỉ Mấy ông buồn ngủ quá
tỉnh lại đi Alo
Ừ tôi không phải vừa dậy mã tấu hài ông
được thì cái đoạn này không có gì ở đâu
phải cả
hết miếu có thể trách tôi vì cái đoạn
này không có gì để tấu hài ông à mà họ
có phải là để cột nhà đâu đúng không ạ
Không phải tấu hài dục được
thôi chị cố dạy dễ hiểu thì tao không để
vừa dậy và hai nước sẽ
say quá
Nói chung là lấy rồi những thông tin này
ông ạ Đấy những cái mình lấy được à À
quên quên quên quên này quên đấy thì ở
trước trước khi mình lấy được thông tin
đấy thì như giờ anh nói đó ạ hành khách
hàng hải đăng nhập rồi ông ạ Mình cần
cho điền lại toàn bộ thông tin này để
khách hàng đỡ phải điện nữa thì mình làm
nha Thì mình sẽ lấy thông tin của cái
thằng đang đăng nhập bằng cách lấy từ
xuân này lấy từ season ID của nó sau đó
kết nối này đây để mình có thể thông tin
của nó sẽ đây này Ai đi khách hàng sẽ
bằng và season II Có ai đi này sau đó
thì lại phải truy vấn vào
lại phạm truy vấn vào à Tao bây thôi Để
lại thông tin khách hàng
không Đừng có lưu lại thông tin khách
hàng này trong rất xinh nhé Thực ra tôi
bảo không nên hẳn lưu lại rồi đấy thì
được cái này thì cần lấy lại chị đấy một
lần thôi cứ sợ mở Where ID bằng id này à
ừ ừ
Ừ tôi cứ cho Điền luôn nhé Thực ra các
ông có thể làm theo kiểu là à
em có cái nút có nút ở đây nhanh được
một là điền hay có nút chết bao này hoặc
giấy thông tin người đang đăng nhập cái
để phải điên này nữa cũng được có một
cách
ở đây này
a
phone number
Anh ở Đại Nghĩa mà đây nữa Thế mình sẽ
phải là phone number VSIP ơ cho nó thống
nhất
anh không gì phải dạ nối à quên quên
quên thiếu Zalo
vì tội bắt đầu buồn ngủ bằng máy
lẽ do mấy ông ấy không phải do tôi đâu
nhé ạ
Em nói như này ok chưa ạ
Ừ đấy Sau đó thì mình mình có thể mình
sửa lại đúng ạ Nhưng thể sửa lại là cho
bạn này thôi đúng ạ thay đổi này đi nghe
sẽ nặn không ạ hồ chí minh rằng
hãy tha
ở Hòa Minh dưỡng nguyện được đúng không
ạ
Ok ở đây lấy hết về này mình vỡ lại con
ếch để đóng Bạn có khách vào
Anh nhắn nhầm con ếch ba này
sau đó thì mình sẽ có câu SQL Insert
into their à
à à quên quên quên quên ngày này quên
Mấy ông cái này một cái đó là
cái này Thực ra là cái tao bên mình nên
thiết kế nó vẫn tức nổi cơ bản các bạn
đã điểm gì
ở đó là mình không có cột ở Tâm Tiền ở
trong order để lấy tổng tiền ra cứ mỗi
lần lấy tổng tiền ra thì mình sẽ phải
nói nô đó xong rồi nhân vào để mở ra em
thường là tôi dậy ở sinh viên Tôi thường
này thêm một cột của Tổng tiên đây tôi
sẽ thêm một cột của Cẩm Tiên nhé
ờ ờ
a Toto Pride điện ảnh
xe tải phim sẽ đẩy + Flash đi
khi cuộc tổng tiền này bạn chất là mình
sẽ
mình mình sẽ tính lại để toàn bộ đơn
hàng này sau đó mình ra cục tổng tiền
đồng ngoại mình lưu nó lại để những lần
sau khi xem lại đơn này thì không cần
phải tính lại nữa họ sẽ nó sẽ tính một
lần thôi Vậy mỗi lần tải lại trang các
bạn lại phải kết nối lại phải nối hai
bạn ấy với nhau ở tính lại thì nó bị
nặng ra nếu hình Dung ạ thì mình nên
tính một lần thôi vì rõ ràng là đơn đơn
đã đặt rồi thì gần như chẳng đổi thay
đổi thay đổi cái tổng tiền chẳng còn như
cháu đã thay đổi cả Không ạ đi cho
nên là bây giờ sẽ không Insert được mấy
ông mình thấy Bây giờ Bây giờ không đi
sớm được mình đã làm tổng tiền này phải
tính đã đúng không ạ Có ông thì sẽ bảo
là tôi đã ký kết một tí nhé Có mình sẽ
bảo là nếu thế thì em có tổng tiền đây
rồi em Chỉ còn truyền cái này qua xin mà
không đặt hàng em chuyển qua thôi thế là
thế càng sai một việc mình phải lấy tổng
tiền từ season mình tính toán ra chứ nếu
mà ông có một cái vai một cái ô input ở
đây này xong rồi có cái tổng tiền đây
thì khách hàng ẩn ẩn concho xem được cái
tổng tiên đấy có cò chuyen.com cũng sửa
cái tổng tiền đấy hạng âm nhạc đặt hàng
thì hoa cái hóa đơn đấy ông phải trả
tiền đó nó không ạ
Ừ thế thì nên là phải toán tổng tiền lại
kêu gì mình phải tính ở trên bác em đừng
có ra tổng tiền đâu mà mình sẽ không xử
lý ở có làm sai được
thì bây giờ mình sẽ nói chung và bây giờ
mình có Sistar đi làm việc về với thí
sinh mà mình sẽ có cát bằng đũa season
tại Cáp này Đấy sau đó thì mình cứ phối
cả đây Các này
a s d shakur Lấy từng thẳng đi
Ừ mình bạn chất là mình có một cái tổng
đấy đi Total file lúc đầu bằng 0
xe ô tô Prime nó sẽ cộng bằng lên tăng
dần lên chị mà X con tê tê
nhân với x tại file sở nào để mình sẽ ra
tổng tiền thôi đó Bên mình có tổng tiền
rồi bây giờ mình Mỹ sơ vào đây
ô coffee house Insert into all those
đi sẽ có
add id id mình để tự động tăng nói đúng
thì
mình sẽ có à
a customer lại đi này có sợ mai đi à
à à
Ừ tôi có cái mẹ mày ngang cho mày không
biết tí nữa nhé em ở nó đầy ở nice này
cho mình có cái này nó nhanh
Tôi có người lười mà ở
a nhớ đương nhiên là có cái dấu nháy này
thì không phải đội nháy rồi ông mấy vợ
nó không thể Bôi đen nó dỡn consume hát
rồi nó vplayer đúng xóa đi nhanh được
Ừ Ok rồi đấy tôi có ba lô nó
Khi nào có cái này à
a modern tất cái
à à
ba ngày là xong
ở ngõ
Ừ ok Ở đây có mấy ông thể tha thứ nhất
là cốt mời đi của mình chưa có Xuân Mai
đi mình bạn chất là đu assistant Tại ai
đi không ạ tiếp theo namely shipper rồi
Fully shipper rồi arrecife
thiếu đồng loại
này đây Atlas này tiếp theo status
status không có đúng không ạ sa tế ớt ở
đây như mình vừa nãy nói mình là sự mình
cái nước không là mới đặt đi những chú
thích đây mới đặt đó như này
a tiếp theo Total Price rồi Crystal
method Mình chưa có mình sẽ góc khuyết
tật Tắt ở đây mấy ông có thể cho Nếu
không có thể không điền cái cột này mình
bé ông cho nó sẵn ở trong dp cũng được
nghĩa là kiểu giá trị mặc định luôn cũng
được hoặc bé ông có thể dùng hàm nào nha
để lấy thời gian hiện thoại từ bên TP
cũng được nhưng mà mình thấy có nhanh
hơn sẽ làm theo cách này bị sẽ ấn
thì mình sẽ quy ước luôn trong đây b là
default là cô đơn tham stem nhà được lấy
luôn thời gian hiện tại chúng mỗi lần
mình khi rót mình không điền vào cột mày
thì nó sẽ lấy theo thời gian hiện tại
cũng nhanh
ở ngã tư nhân có chấm phẩy đây
à Dạ Mình Sai rồi Sai rồi à
anh xem lại nhé status này tôi quan có
phải đúng đấy
Ừ ok
em thấy mình đang dậy rất à từ từ và cố
chỉ ra các bạn vài cái đấy ông ạ
Tối đoạn nào tối ưu không ạ
I bami thử đai câu truy vấn ra
các bạn xem nha
đó nó sẽ như thế này
à Có sao mai đi là năm này tên mình thử
in xuất chai vào trong này đã sẽ bị sốt
được không
ở đó anh xuất thành công nó sẽ thành
công mình cứ tạm xóa đi á ấy đã
anh ở đây mình mình một lúc và mình muốn
đi xa tận hai vàng cùng lúc sau đó Xóa
luôn cả giỏ hàng đấy Đặt hàng rồi không
chuyện chở hàng vẫn còn không ạ
a a a
anh ở đây mình sẽ in xuất luôn cái rọ Hà
ý thì cái Yên số giỏ hàng ngày thì bạn
chất là nó hơi bị có người vấn đề này để
không để ý nhá nó có đây đi tất cả chỉ
là mình phải lấy đúng vào đây đi mà Mình
vừa mới như giấc
em ở trên này lấy nó về đúng ạ thì có
một cái trường hợp này có thể xảy ra này
đó là nhiều người cùng đặt cái giỏ hài
cùng lúc
anh nhịn bài toán để ăn nhiều người
không phải cùng tỏ hàng mà ý tôi ở nhiều
người cùng top 1 cùng một lúc thì nếu mà
ông lỡ vừa mày Insert cái thằng này vì
rất là này
à mà không lấy mắt lại salad mắc ID của
thằng mắc lớn nhất thì thế Đàn ông vừa
vì đáp đúng không ạ của cái
có cái order đấy thì đôi khi là nó sẽ bị
nhầm sang ai đi của cái thằng mà nó vừa
đặt cùng lúc với ông ở một ở một nơi
khác nhận nó cũng đã thế thì mắc này đôi
khi nó 01
cho nó hiểu thì thôi em ạ này Shake Mac
ID này
for dead
Ừ để để lấy được ID lớn nhất không ạ
khi mẹ bị ốm hiểu họ lấy order phải đi
được truyền sang Idol vô đắt này nhập
vào truyền là màn không ạ
Ừ thì bây giờ có cách đó là mếu thể thêm
đoạn quay ở đây mời đi Bằng chính cái
thằng mà mình
mình vừa mình đang bật cái thằng nào thì
mình sẽ mắc thì nó sẽ gần như nó sẽ nó
đúng hơn chứ Khi ông ông khách hàng này
còn tạo ra 2 trang thời trang để mà
cùng cùng đợt hàng nữa thì có khi còn
vấn đề nữa
ib1 Mẹ của tôi thôi Nếu không có thể
chơi mẹo chắc cú hơn và mày ông sẽ sẽ
ngay từ lúc đầu mày ông salad mắt trước
như và mấy ông không cho ai đi tự động
tăng mấy ông sẽ không cho ai đi tự động
tăng
à Mà ông salad mắt trước sau đó mới ông
y-shirt thẳng vào trong dp theo 10id
cũng được theo kiểu như thế này nhá thì
tôi chỉ em với ông dễ hình dung nhé Mấy
ông theo cách nào có hay có 2cách nhé
Tôi sẽ luôn đời suốt ông những cái hướng
giải quyết bài toán này mấy ông hình
dung cái tư duy lập trình thế tôi đang
dạy không bản chất vẫn là tư duy lập
trình chứ không phải là dạy cho ông ấy
Ông chỉ biết cốc thôi Biết cốt thôixem
thêm sửa xóa mấy ông ấy biết rồi ông ạ
Tôi đang dậy mấy ông những cái khó nhất
này chỉ là thứ duy lập trình đó là
tác giả phở
niệm đầu tiên thì trường hợp một cách
một đi cách 1 Shake mắc ID từ đây à Ừ
nếu mà chỉ lấy ngày thôi ông ạ thì nó sẽ
có vấn đề là
nếu
người dùng
cùng đặt hàng
anh một lúc cơ à
ký xuất cùng lúc trở lại thì cái mắc ai
đi Mắc AD này chưa chắc là đúng ngay đi
của cái thằng mà vừa mới ăn rất vào nó
ID của cô đơn khác của cái thằng B em ạ
thì khi các bạn Insert vào trong order
codes
đi theo cái others đi đấy thì nó là sai
ông ạ anh nó say nên là mình vừa bảo là
các bạn một là các bạn sẽ well có số 10
đi nữa những cái trình diễn thảm đang
đặt đơn Nó có vẻ ổn hơn vì nó vừa mới
đặt mà đúng ạ
ở đấy đến trường học một con cá trường
hợp cách cách giải quyết một khoảng cách
giải quyết hay đó là các bạn sẽ selec
này ngay từ lúc đó các bạn sẽ cho cái
sonax này ngày thứ đầu trên này
đang ở chế này chẳng hạn như này không
cần que cái gì đó nữa sau đó thì giờ sự
ra đời một cái ID điều đó
em lấy từ cái đoạn này ra một cái gì đó
cho các bạn sẽ in xuất thẳng vào trong
này kèm theo cái đi luôn như thế này và
ở và ở dưới này các bạn sẽ dùng một này
đi đấy in sớm mà sao đầu blog cũng được
Ừ cũng được các bạn không để cho cột ID
là tự động tăng nữa có bạn sẽ in such ai
vào
Ừ Thì Mình thấy cách này nó hợp vị hơn
cái này nó sẽ luôn đúng
Anh ta sẽ luôn đúng
anh bởi vì là khi mà selects mắc này nếu
là sự ý xuất và nó bị lỗi là sử vẫn có
hai người đặt cùng một lúc thì sẽ lên
mắc này sau đó ý rất là bị lỗi ông ạ thì
mình chỉ thì chắc chắn là một hành lỗi
một hàng thanh toán được còn hơn việc ạ
Thằng này đặt đơn sản phẩm của thằng này
nhảy vào đơn thằng kia nó hơi sai đấy
mấy ông ấy giờ có tiền ngủ hôm nay bây
giờ một tiếng bốn phút 23 phút rồi thì
cũng hơi dài bố mày hơi dài hi vọng mấy
ông Lễ vẫn tịch
Ừ thôi thì chắc là tôi áp dụng bằng cách
đơn giản hơn cho mấy ông dễ dễ hình dung
nhé
anh không bị ngủ hết rồi
thì mình sẽ có đây là à
à à
cả hai
ông kia động viên rồi à
Anh
ấy thấy gian hai lớp vải dù chẳng hết à
chú ý bạn là cái ngày đúng không cái này
thật ra như mình nói Thật ra cũng cũng
được nhưng mà cũng có trường nào xảy ra
thằng cu Summer đấy nó bằng một lí do
thần thái muốn chơi trò đấy cả là nó
cùng cùng Đăng nhập cùng một nick của
thận hai máy là Nhạn thì sẽ ăn nó khác
mà bọn Sơn vẫn khác nhé thế là cùng một
nick nhưng mà vẫn tạo ra 2 phiên giữa
rừng nó cung đặt thì nó sẽ nó sẽ cái mắt
AD vẫn có thể có vấn đề thì các trường
hợp hai nó sẽ đúng hơn hộp 2 thì tự
nhiên mình nói là có trường hợp mà hai
hàng cúi sát tại một thằng bị lỗi rồi ạ
thì khi mà bị lỗi thì mình có thể bắt
được cái lỗi đấy mình tăng ai đi lên đấy
nó sẽ không đổi nữa ừ ừ
khi con gái trường hợp này thì vẫn có
thể sai trường hợp này vẫn thể sai ý
e-mail web cho bị spam thời giảm hay quá
cơ hội tôi không cần cái lời đâu mà ông
ngồi học đi à
em
tắt đi à
Không nhớ cái này không ạ Mình lấy thử
cái dọn hàng ra mình sẽ cỏ cô đã phải đi
ở đây và đây ít này nó sẽ có con Ti
Em có biết were D băng
research into your therefore I
ừ ừ
à à
I
want it I mình sẽ lấy à
Bạn đôla x tại quantity
và bây giờ chỉ đơn giản nhưng sẽ truy
vấn mà thôi
nếu không sẽ thấy có bao nhiêu sản phẩm
trong cái rọ Hà mình sẽ in giấc 7 ngư
dân và muộn muộn một là mấy ông sẽ đi
xuất cảnh ngay nó sẽ bị Hơi nhược điểm
một tí ạ và sẽ mất mấy như lần câu truy
vấn bằng cách giữa hai ở mấy ông có thể
chơi được Kiểu là nối chuỗi cũng được nó
làm gì ở tạo một câu Insert ở trên này
sau đó thì nối chuỗi value value thêm
vào sau đó của cô ấy chạy một thể một
cái quay đấy cũng được thì đỡ phải có
bao nhiêu lần sơ nhé mình em dụng cách
đơn giản để nó như này thôi Mỹ Tâm
Chuyện xót nha Em tải lại trang
xin lỗi à
ờ ờ đầu tiên xem lỗi này dòng 23 đổi gì
Ừ cái này đã
u-mac ID for mother always customer ID
đang báo lỗi cái câu câu truy vấn này có
vấn đề thế nên là cái cái con ếch này nó
không chặn không trả về được giá trị khi
muốn thì sẽ đang ở đây ft out chạy trai
đã
à à
khi trở về ngồi nghỉ trở về mà
- xuất quả lại a rồi mình phải đi sơ ta
xin lỗi xin lỗi mình chuyên shop mà sao
không được để Insert cả rồi sao sẽ lách
này à
à à
anh vẫn lỗi vòng 21
I Connect này Ừ nhưng mà nó sao
ừ ừ
hai anh em nhà tôi nhầm hàm Tôi xin lỗi
Tôi nhầm Hà An
ừ ừ
à à
anh không báo lỗi nữa không có lỗi không
nghĩa chạy được không ạ Cứ thử đã
a research Ok này Total Price có vẻ ổn ở
đây wonderflex đó Gold rồi đó ok Bây giờ
mình chỉ cần đóng kết nối dẫn tả
xóa cái
xóa xin thôi mình sẽ ăn xét
và season tại khác để xóa đi
bởi vì bây giờ cũng mỗi mình tả lại sang
nói in sẽ lại phát nữa này các bạn thấy
nó lại thêm một hóa đơn nữa Ngại thế
không được không ạ khi ở mình thanh toán
này xong mình sẽ phải header quay trở
lại trang cậu thông báo thành công những
cái gì đó tôi thì tự điều hướng với
trang chủ và cả trang người dùng để mà
người dùng có thể xem lại đơn vẫn thứ
sau không ạ
anh nói chung là bây giờ chạy lại thì
các bạn sẽ xin lỗi vì rõ là sai rồi ông
ạ
ở nhà xe lửa hành vừa nó chống nóng lỗi
này cũng chưa tôi phải làm vài đoạn này
khi đó đại khái như thế
trong bộ hôm nay à
Khi bữa hôm nay mấy ông thấy à thực ra
nó rất là dài thì ra nó tk cốt ngắn
nhưng mà tôi phải giải thích rất kỹ rất
nhiều thế thành ra nó dài như này à
à à
Ừ
Cái vụ mà shopee đăng nhập Hai thiết bị
hay lượng chữ N thiết bị nó cùng một dầu
21 vì cái giỏ hàng này nó lưu lại trên
sốc trên đó Bây này do mà ông vào bất kỳ
Ừ cái thiết bị nào mấy ông nhà vẫn xem
được cái giỏ hàng giống nhau vì nó lừa ở
trong đây bê được ở trong đây còn mình
đang dậy luận chung xuân thành ra là cứ
một thiết bị là y rằng là một cái giỏ
hàng mới giờ hàng khác để mở mình mở
bằng danh này xinh Em do hàng nữa ngoặt
sang nhà cậu khi mà cùng một tài khoản
mà cùng cùng bạc hàng ấy thì cũng có
trường hợp mà kiểu tạo ra order 2 đ** đồ
và hai kéo đời đi Đấy nó thì chúng ta
cái mắc godaddy nó sẽ có một cơ mà không
ạ hàng ra thì thành em một order sẽ có
nhiều sản phẩm có đời kia con cho đời
còn lại không có sản phẩm nào Tất cả
cũng chắc là không có trường hợp người
dùng cùng làm thế đâu ông ạ
Ừ Chắc không có đâu không ạ Nhưng mà
thường là thật ra không ai chơi xin kẹo
ngay cả như mình nói nghe cái bài toán
mình chỉ ăn nói ở mức giải quyết được
vấn đề Nếu giờ sự các bạn ở thắc mắc gì
thì nó có gửi do gì không ạ
Hình như tôi đã nói thì tôi đang dạy mấy
ông ạ tư duy lập trình chúng mày dạy mày
không về cốt không ạ Vì cốt để thờ ca
mấy ông thật ra mấy ông thấy Cốt nó rất
là ngắn và cũng là mấy ông phải có cốt
này về là nó ra trong web bán hàng rồi
nhưng là Nhưng mà nếu không có tư duy
thì mày ông không thể phát triển được
thêm một cái nữa không ạ
à à
Ừ đúng rồi chúng ta là không cần nó tin
vẫn thể đạt được ha noisinh Ở đây chỉ
đơn giản là như hồi trước thì mình bạo
loạn để mà tránh việc là người dùng tạo
giác nhiều đặt đơn quá thì mình có cho
đăng ký có về đỡ hơn tí ngoại và lẫn cả
là để cho có khái niệm mà khách hàng Bạn
xem được đơn hàng cũ đã đặt ông ạ Có bên
khách hàng đăng nhập đăng ký do nó chuẩn
chỉ có một cái trang web đó nhé
à Có chứ thêm Phong địa chỉ rồi mà mày
ông quen à
đã có lãi thông tin địa chỉ người nhận
rồi
à à
Ừ đúng rồi Cái này gần như sởi ép lắm
Đăng ký
đặt ở thì ra cũng có khá nhiều trang web
vì thế mà cho thêm sản phẩm vào giỏ hàng
nó cứ thứ xong đến cuối thì vẫn bắt đăng
ký mới cho thanh toán mà à
Ừ Từ hôm nay còn định chia sẻ thêm người
nữa cơ ngoài tôi chia sẻ là được ạ chẳng
ở đây tôi sẽ nốt một cái giải trí mấy
ông này Thế có hôm trước có một ông hỏi
là
hôm trước anh cài cái gì để mà chạy hiển
thị điều cái trang medium thì tôi hôm ấy
tô của nó chỉ cách mấy ông mở cái IP
config Lên Điểm IP sửa cái DNS của nó để
mà vào được cái trang màu trời xanh mà
Việt Nam đang bị chặn không ạ trạm địa
chỉ IP Ừ thì mình sẽ đổi DNS sang của
Google là của
U11 là nhiều của em là mất à cái kiểu
thế hoặc cả mấy ông có thể cài thêm cái
cái
nó là
cloudflare nè này thôi nó không biết
phát tởm cái đằng sau nó gì quá mà Đấy
cái cái VPN kiểu như này đến mấy ông thể
truy cập được vào trang web có thể trang
web đen được không ạ
Đấy thì
chợ hoa tiện ích ở trên mạng có một vài
tx Nhưng mà nếu giờ sự mấy ông cài mình
cứ lấy Vào mà vẫn không Vẫn không được
thì mới ông có vài trang có trang này à
Ở trang này nó tên đọc tên rồi nó thể
hiểu luôn rồi Nó là mấy ông có thể liền
biết cái xanh nào vào đây để kiểm tra
xem trang đây đã sập nó có sắp thực thực
sự hay không Hay là chỉ còn hơn giản ông
không gọi được thôi là sự ông không vào
được mấy home ngoãn với ông gõ mir vào
đây rồi xong rồi ấn nút này ngọn nó sẽ
thông báo cho em cái Trang đấy có thực
sự sập phải không Hay là mỗi mình gọi
ông không được lại tôi sử dụng nhé trang
Google rồi mà Bởi vì nhiều lúc ông thấy
à Facebook không bị ơi ông ạ Ông Thực
bấm vào đây sẽ xem ra đối với người khác
thì Facebook của bạn được không đấy
anh
không chỉ với bạn thôi Google vẫn lên
tại Chẳng thế bởi vì đã tự Và thậm chí
có phải Trang tương tự như này nó còn
liệt kê cả cụ thể thời gian mà cái trang
này đã bị sập bao lâu rồi anh ấy rất là
hay
từ lần trước ở vụ Facebook sập 4 phút
thì phải mất cũng khá nhiều cổ phiếu hội
để mất gần 2 triệu đô chỉ còn 4 cũ đây ạ
ở trong trong cái khóa học này thì cậu
không không còn ngôn ngữ nào nữa còn
khóa sau thì
anh không còn ngôn ngữ là nữa cũng sẽ
chỉ chuyên về thì ra Swift nữa thể paleo
thôi mình không biết về mấy cái ngôn ngữ
khác từ ra mình
nhà mình có biết thì mình không thạo lắm
em mình không dậy được các bạn mày một
cái đấy
các bạn về sau các bạn cứ học ngôn ngữ
một ngôn ngữ rồi Các bạn thấy tự nhiên
là thấy có thể không hứng thú nó lắm thì
nhảy sang hạn khác vẫn được mà không sao
Ừ Ok Google hôm nay quá dài rồi gần hai
tiếng thôi mình sẽ tạm ngừng tại đây nhé
Mọi thắc mắc ý kiến Xin vui lòng liên hệ
đó à thì liên hệ mình qua Facebook đầy
đủ tất cả kênh hoặc bình luận video sau
nhé
ý là có lollia chứ nhưng mà khóa sẵn
khóa khác Xin chào các bạn nhé Có mình
sẽ dạy các bạn về Abi nhưng mà cũng là
khóa sau